This January on Paramount Plus, it began on the shores of New Jersey. Now a new pack emerges in the Great White North. Canada Shore, new original series, now streaming on Paramount Plus. It is impossible to withhold our admiration for Hannibal's leadership, his courage and his ability in the field when we consider the duration of his campaigns and take note of the major and minor battles, the sieges, the defections of cities from one side to the other, the difficulties he encountered at various times, and in short, the whole scope of his design and its execution. For 16 years, he waged ceaseless war against the Romans in Italy,
今年一月在派拉蒙流媒体平台（Paramount Plus），故事始于新泽西州的海岸。如今，一股新的势力在北方大国崛起。《加拿大海岸》（Canada Shore），全新原创剧集，现已在派拉蒙流媒体平台上线。当我们审视汉尼拔战役的持续时间，并注意到大大小小的战役、围城战、城市倒戈、他在不同时期遇到的困难，简而言之，当我们审视他整个计划及其执行过程时，我们无法不钦佩汉尼拔的领导力、勇气和他在战场上的能力。十六年来，他在意大利对罗马人发动了不间断的战争，
and the whole while, like a good pilot, he kept the love and loyalty of his forces. He had with him Africans, Iberians, Gauls, Carthaginians, Italians and Greeks, men who had nothing naturally in common, neither in their laws, their customs, their language, nor in any other respect. Nonetheless, the skill of their commander was such that he could impose the authority of a single voice and a single will, even upon men of such totally diverse origins. If only he'd subdued other parts of the world first and finished with the Romans, not one of his projects would have eluded him.
在此期间，他像一位优秀的飞行员一样，始终保持着军队的爱戴与忠诚。他麾下有非洲人、伊比利亚人、高卢人、迦太基人、意大利人和希腊人，这些人天生没有任何共同点，无论是在法律、习俗、语言还是其他任何方面。尽管如此，这位指挥官的才华足以让他将单一的声音和意志强加于这些出身完全不同的人身上。如果他能先征服世界其他地区，最后再解决罗马人，那么他的任何计划都不会落空。
But as it was, since he turned his attention first to those whom he should have dealt with last, his career began and ended with them. So that was the Greek historian Plibeius. It's one of those passages that seems written precisely to torment 16-year-old schoolboys and schoolgirls in British schools in the 1940s or something, sort of slogging their way through his torture. prose. Belibius, like him or loathe him, he's our best source for the Punic Wars. And here, in this thrilling passage, he is singing the praises of the great Carthaginian general Hannibal. Now, in today's episode, we are coming to the great showdown of the Punic Wars, one of the most titanic clashes in all history. This is the showdown between the Romans and the Carthaginians at the Battle of Zama.
但事实是，由于他首先将注意力转向了本应最后处理的对象，他的职业生涯便始于他们，也终于他们。以上就是希腊历史学家波利比乌斯的观点。这段文字似乎就是为了折磨20世纪40年代英国学校里那些16岁的学生而写的，他们不得不费力地研读他那晦涩的散文。波利比乌斯，无论你喜欢还是讨厌他，他都是我们了解布匿战争的最佳史料来源。而在这里，在这段激动人心的文字中，他正在歌颂伟大的迦太基将军汉尼拔。在今天的节目中，我们将迎来布匿战争的终极对决，这是历史上最震撼的冲突之一。这就是罗马人与迦太基人在扎马战役中的决战。
And we'll come to this in a little while. But first, let's have a little chat about Polybius himself. Because Tom, he knew Rome well, and he knew the subject very well. He had interviewed leading figures in the war against Hannibal, hadn't he? He admired the Roman system of government. And actually, he was quite a fan of the Roman Imperium more broadly. Yes, even though he was a Greek. And it's slightly disappointed that you didn't follow up your brilliant impression of Livy
我们稍后会讲到这一点。但首先，让我们聊聊波利比乌斯本人。因为汤姆，他很了解罗马，也非常了解这个主题。他采访过对阵汉尼拔战争中的主要人物，不是吗？他钦佩罗马的政府体制。事实上，他更广泛地来说是罗马帝国（Imperium）的崇拜者。是的，尽管他是个希腊人。我很失望你没有在上一集中延续你对李维的精彩模仿，
in our last episode with a... by doing a Greek accent for Polybius. I did think about it, but I didn't do it. But you ducked it. Yeah, so Polybius, for reasons that we will come to, he knows Rome very, very well indeed, and he is particularly close to the family of the Scipio's, and they are the family that, as we heard in the previous episode,
而是用希腊口音来演绎波利比乌斯。我确实考虑过，但我没做。但你躲过去了。是的，所以波利比乌斯，出于我们稍后会提到的原因，他确实非常非常了解罗马，而且他与西庇阿家族关系特别密切，正如我们在上一集中听到的那样，他们是那个家族，
they played the kind of the leading role in the great Rome's great death struggle with Hannibal. So when it comes to the Punic Wars, Polybius is pretty clearly team Rome, but even so, as we heard, in that opening passage, he can't help but admire Hannibal. And the reasons are self-evident. Hannibal is the man who has led a great army over the Alps into Italy. He's killed 100,000 Roman, perhaps, in three terrible and tactically brilliant battles, and who, as Polybius noted in that
在罗马与汉尼拔的生死存亡之战中扮演了主导角色。所以当谈到布匿战争时，波利比乌斯显然是站在罗马这一边的，但即便如此，正如我们刚才听到的，在那段开场白中，他还是忍不住钦佩汉尼拔。原因是不言而喻的。汉尼拔是一个率领大军翻越阿尔卑斯山进入意大利的人。他在三场战术极其精妙的惨烈战役中杀死了可能多达十万名罗马人，正如波利比乌斯在那段
passage, had kept a force made up of many disparate peoples in the field for a decade and more, in a foreign land separated by the seas from Carthage, his native city. So an unbelievable achievement. Now the Romans, unlike Polybius, were not generally in the habit of praising Hannibal. And the reason for that is that they feared and hated him too much. But I think with the Romans, if you have their hatred and their fear, they are paying you a kind of compliment. Of course.
文字中所指出的，他将一支由许多不同民族组成的军队在异国他乡维持了十年之久，而那里与他的故乡迦太基隔海相望。这真是一个令人难以置信的成就。现在，罗马人与波利比乌斯不同，他们通常没有赞美汉尼拔的习惯。原因在于他们太害怕也太憎恨他了。但我认为，对于罗马人来说，如果你能得到他们的仇恨和恐惧，他们其实是在给你一种恭维。当然。
Yeah. They know the man they are facing. I mean, they know that they are facing one of the greatest generals of all time. Now, that said, by 204 BC, Hannibal's fortunes, this guy who at one point had seemed on the verge of destroying Roman power for good, his fortunes are much, much diminished. So by 204 BC, he's been in Italy for 14 years. And, you know, that is four times the length of the first. First World War. So that gives you some sense of what an ordeal this has been. It's been a
是的。他们知道自己面对的是什么人。我的意思是，他们知道自己面对的是有史以来最伟大的将军之一。话虽如此，到了公元前204年，汉尼拔的命运——这个曾经一度似乎即将彻底摧毁罗马力量的人——已经大不如前了。所以到了公元前204年，他在意大利已经待了14年。你知道，那是第一次世界大战长度的四倍。这让你对这场磨难的程度有所了解。这是一场
marathon, not a sprint. It really has. And the problem for Hannibal is that, as we heard in the previous episode, the Romans have conquered Spain, which was essentially the place where he was relying on for reinforcements and for supplies and for money and all kinds of things. So that's terrible. His allies in Italy have fallen away. And he is now essentially cornered in Brutium, which is the heel of Italy. But even now, the Romans are incredibly reluctant to engage him in battle. They just think, if we go and fight him, he will defeat us. That is the kind of hoodoo that he has over them. And so their plan now is to just bypass him altogether. And they're going to do this by invading Africa. And this strategy had been articulated the year before by the man who has been mandated
马拉松，而不是短跑。确实如此。汉尼拔的问题在于，正如我们在上一集中听到的，罗马人征服了西班牙，而西班牙本质上是他依赖增援、补给、资金和各种物资的地方。所以这太糟糕了。他在意大利的盟友已经纷纷离去。他现在基本上被困在布鲁提姆，也就是意大利的“脚后跟”。但即使到了现在，罗马人仍然极其不愿与他交战。他们只是认为，如果我们去和他打，他会打败我们。这就是他给他们带来的那种心理阴影。所以他们现在的计划是完全绕过他。他们打算通过入侵非洲来做到这一点。而这一战略是前一年由那个被授权
by the Roman Republic to execute it. So to quote him, I shall draw Hannibal after me. I shall force him to fight on his native soil, and the prize of victory will be not some run-down forts in Brutium. Carthage itself. And the man who is speaking these words, he's only 30, but he has already established himself as the greatest military hero in Rome's history. And this is the young, long-haired, smoothly shaved, Publis Cornelius Scipio. So in the last episode, we heard how over the previous four years, Scipio had destroyed Carthage's power base in Spain.
执行此任务的罗马共和国人物所提出的。引用他的话：“我将把汉尼拔引向我。我将迫使他在他的本土作战，而胜利的奖赏将不是布鲁提姆的一些破旧堡垒，而是迦太基本身。”而说出这些话的人，他只有30岁，但他已经确立了自己作为罗马历史上最伟大军事英雄的地位。这就是年轻、长发、刮得干干净净的普布利乌斯·科尔内利乌斯·西庇阿。所以在上一集中，我们听到了在过去的四年里，西庇阿是如何摧毁迦太基在西班牙的权力基础的。
So by doing that, he had eliminated the manpower and the mineral wealth that had sustained Hannibal's war effort and on which Hannibal had been relying for reinforcements to finish his own war. effort in Italy. Skipio had gone back to Rome, hadn't he? We discussed this at the end of the last episode. He'd gone back to Rome as the great hero of the air, the hero of the Roman people, the darling of the masses.
通过这样做，他消除了维持汉尼拔战争努力的人力和矿产财富，而汉尼拔正是依靠这些来获得增援以完成他在意大利的战争。西庇阿回到了罗马，不是吗？我们在上一集结尾讨论过这个问题。他作为那个时代的伟大英雄、罗马人民的英雄、大众的宠儿回到了罗马。
He had won the consulship. He had been appointed to the command in Sicily. And he had explicitly been given license to invade North Africa, quote, if he judged it to be in the interests of the Republic. And Tom, you entered the last episode by saying, we will discover if he does. Obviously, the implication is that he will. He does. He does think it's in the interest in the Republic, even though there are people in the
他赢得了执政官职位。他被任命为西西里岛的指挥官。并且他明确获得了入侵北非的许可，“如果他认为这符合共和国的利益的话”。汤姆，你上一集的结尾说，我们将发现他是否会这样做。显然，暗示是他会这样做。他确实做了。他确实认为这符合共和国的利益，尽管在
Senate who are a little bit more cautious, aren't there? Yes, and regular listeners to this series will not be surprised that the guy who takes the lead in opposing this strategy is Fabius Maximus contartal, the De Leia. The guy who back in the wake of late Trasamine had been appointed dictator, so put in supreme control of the Roman state for six months, and he had adopted this strategy of shadowing Hannibal, of never engaging him in battle, which then provided the template for Roman strategy in the wake of Cannae, and which is still being adopted in 204 BC. He's now, I mean, unbelievably old. He's about 130. And he is a figure of enormous status. So he has the official title, Prinkep Sinatus. He's the chief senator. And Fabius had directly
元老院里有一些人比较谨慎，不是吗？是的，这个系列的常客不会对那个带头反对这一战略的人感到惊讶，他就是“拖延者”费边·马克西姆斯。那个在特拉西梅诺湖战役后被任命为独裁官，即在六个月内掌握罗马国家最高控制权的人，他采取了跟踪汉尼拔、从不与他交战的战略，这为坎尼战役后的罗马战略提供了模板，并且在公元前204年仍然被采用。他现在，我的意思是，老得不可思议。他大约130岁了。他是一个地位极高的人物。所以他拥有正式头衔“元老院首席”（Princeps Senatus）。他是首席元老。而费边曾直接
accused Scipio in the debate about whether he should be given permission. to invade Africa. He accused Scipio of endangering Rome's security by leading an expedition to Africa while Hannibal was still current and present in Italy with his own army. So Fabius had directly accused Skipio essentially of glory hunting. Your glory matters less to me, he told Skipio, than the welfare of our city. If you really want to destroy Hannibal, then go to Brutium and fight him there, which is, I mean, a very stinging rebuke. And I think it's clearly animated by a kind of personal animus as well as anxiety about strategy. And I think it portrays what right from the beginning of Scipio's career has been an anxiety on the part of conservative elements in the Senate about his character.
在关于是否应该给予西庇阿入侵非洲许可的辩论中指责他。他指责西庇阿在汉尼拔仍然在意大利且拥有军队的情况下，通过领导远征非洲来危及罗马的安全。所以费边基本上直接指责西庇阿是为了追求荣耀。他对西庇阿说：“你的荣耀对我来说，不如我们城市的福祉重要。”如果你真的想消灭汉尼拔，那就去布鲁提姆和他打，这真是一个非常尖锐的斥责。我认为这显然是由一种个人敌意以及对战略的焦虑所激发的。而且我认为这反映了从西庇阿职业生涯一开始，元老院中保守派对他性格的焦虑。
Yeah, part of this is his youth, right? And his glamour and his eye for sort of, as it were, a Roman photo opportunity. It's about his hair and his shiny cheeks. His claims to have been born from a serpent, all of that stuff. Right, his general sense of un-Romaness, of Greekness even. And of course, we mentioned in the previous episode that while he had been in Spain, some of the Iberian warlords had hailed him as a king, a word that for the Romans, you know, is the most sort of shocking and toxic label that there could possibly be.
是的，部分原因是他的年轻，对吧？还有他的魅力，以及他那种对罗马式“拍照机会”的敏锐眼光。关于他的头发，他那红润的脸颊。他声称自己是蛇所生，所有这些东西。没错，他那种普遍的“非罗马感”，甚至“希腊感”。当然，我们在上一集中提到，当他在西班牙时，一些伊比利亚军阀曾称他为国王，这个词对于罗马人来说，你知道，是可能存在的最令人震惊和有毒的标签。
Everything about him just seems wrong, doesn't it? It just seems un-Roman. It's not just as he's been hailed king, but that he is incredibly popular, both with his troops and with the mass of the Roman people. So in Spain, in the wake of his great victories, his soldiers had taken to hailing him as Imperator, which is the word that means general,
关于他的一切似乎都不对劲，不是吗？这看起来很不罗马。不仅仅是因为他被尊为国王，还因为他在军队和广大罗马民众中都非常受欢迎。所以在西班牙，在他取得伟大胜利之后，他的士兵们开始称他为“统帅”（Imperator），这个词的意思是将军，
but which in the long run will become the title that Augustus claims and which gives us our title of emperor. So it doesn't have that connotation at this point. But nevertheless, it's a straw in the wind. I mean, no one has been hailed in this way before. And so senators back in Rome are anxious about this. And they're also anxious about the fact that he's become consul when he's only 30 and you're meant to be 40.
但从长远来看，它将成为奥古斯都所宣称的头衔，并赋予了我们“皇帝”（Emperor）这个词。所以它在当时还没有那种含义。但尽管如此，这还是一个风向标。我的意思是，以前没有人被这样称呼过。所以罗马的元老们对此感到焦虑。他们还担心他只有30岁就成了执政官，而你本应是40岁。
And essentially, he's been swept to power on a great wave of popular enthusiasm. And so there's a sort of nervous as what will he do with this power, I think. But Scipio, he's not having any of this. and he throws Fabius' criticisms back in his face and he says that if you block my intention to invade Africa, then I am going to turn to the people and I will get them to force this strategy through. You know, you Fabius and all your conservative allies in the Senate,
而且本质上，他是在一股巨大的民众热情浪潮中被推上权力的。所以我认为，人们对“他将如何利用这种权力”感到一种紧张。但西庇阿，他根本不吃这一套，他把费边的批评反击了回去，他说如果你们阻止我入侵非洲的意图，那么我将转向人民，我会让他们强行通过这一战略。你知道，你费边和你元老院里所有的保守派盟友，
you will be publicly humiliated. And so Fabius essentially steps down and the conservatives very reluctantly give him the green light. So the summer of 204, Scipio's expedition set sail from Sicily. He has his troop ships, his troop transports, and they're escorted by 40 warships. Scipio and his brother Lucius are commanding the right wing, as it were, of the fleet, 20 ships, and the 20 ships on the left wing are commanded by his friend Lelius, who we talked about last time, and by a young paymaster called Marcus Porteus Cato.
你们将被公开羞辱。所以费边基本上退缩了，保守派非常勉强地给了他绿灯。所以204年的夏天，西庇阿的远征队从西西里岛起航。他有他的运兵船，他的部队运输船，并由40艘战舰护航。西庇阿和他的兄弟卢修斯指挥着舰队的右翼，也就是20艘船，左翼的20艘船由他的朋友莱利乌斯指挥，我们上次谈到过他，还有一位年轻的财务官，名叫马尔库斯·波尔基乌斯·加图。
And Cato, a name that will recur in Roman history. He is a young man with reddish hair and grey eyes. He is in his early 30s, as Scipio is. But his political identity is very different, isn't it? So Cato is the most traditional of the traditionalists, the most conservative of the conservatives. He is a big admirer of Fabius Maximus. And he's an impressive man, but he is by no.
加图，这个名字将在罗马历史上反复出现。他是一个有着红头发和灰眼睛的年轻人。他和西庇阿一样，三十出头。但他的政治身份非常不同，不是吗？所以加图是传统派中最传统的，保守派中最保守的。他是费边·马克西姆斯的崇拜者。他是一个令人印象深刻的人，但他绝不是
means a natural ally of somebody like Scipio. No, he's followed all the rules. He has this post of the paymaster. He's a quaister it's called. So he's responsible for keeping an eye on Scipio's spending. And that is absolutely the kind of role that someone of his age should have. You know, he's not swanning around like a console with long hair and talking about snakes. Right.
像西庇阿那样的人的天然盟友。不，他遵守了所有的规则。他担任财务官这个职位，也就是所谓的“财务官”（Quaestor）。所以他负责监视西庇阿的开支。这绝对是一个像他这个年纪的人应该担任的角色。你知道，他不像一个留着长发、谈论蛇的执政官那样到处招摇。没错。
He is performatively conservative. That means that he's absolutely not a Scipio soulmate. But of course, waiting for Scipio in Africa is a guy who absolutely is a Scipio soulmate. And that is his old mate, Massenissa. So we met him in the previous episode. He's a Numidian king who had fought in Spain, first of all for the Carthaginians, and had then changed sides and become a big ally of Scipio and Rome. And Masonissa has every reason to welcome Scipio's arrival with open arms.
他是表演性的保守。这意味着他绝对不是西庇阿的灵魂伴侣。但当然，在非洲等待西庇阿的是一个绝对是西庇阿灵魂伴侣的人。那就是他的老朋友马西尼萨。我们在上一集中见过他。他是一位努米底亚国王，最初在西班牙为迦太基人作战，后来倒戈，成为了西庇阿和罗马的大盟友。马西尼萨有充分的理由张开双臂欢迎西庇阿的到来，
because just as Rome is engaged in a death struggle with Carthage, Massanissa is engaged in a death struggle of his own, because people who listened to our last episode may remember, he is not the only Numidian king. There is another king who leads his own federation of Numidian tribes, and this is a guy called Syfax. And Massanissa has been fighting him all his life. So as a teenager, he had kind of had the beating of Sifax, and that was what it had then enabled him to travel to Spain and fight for the Carthaginians.
因为正如罗马正与迦太基进行生死搏斗一样，马西尼萨也在进行着他自己的生死搏斗，因为听过我们上一集的人可能还记得，他不是唯一的努米底亚国王。还有另一位国王领导着他自己的努米底亚部落联盟，这就是一个叫西法克斯的人。马西尼萨一生都在与他作战。所以十几岁的时候，他曾击败过西法克斯，这使他能够前往西班牙为迦太基人作战。
But he's now come back and Sifax is still on the scene and still causing all kinds of trouble. And the fact that Massenissa has come back to Africa as an ally of the Romans means that Sifax, who previously had been an ally of the Romans, has now obviously swung around and become an ally of the Carthaginians. That's the way diplomacy works. But there's another element, isn't there? So there's one thing that in this story, this story has had everything, of course, except one element. There's one element that's been missing. And it's brilliant to be able to unveil that element now in the third episode of this series. And that element is a woman.
但他现在回来了，西法克斯仍然在场，并且仍然在制造各种麻烦。马西尼萨作为罗马人的盟友回到非洲，意味着之前曾是罗马人盟友的西法克斯，现在显然已经倒戈，成为了迦太基人的盟友。外交就是这样运作的。但还有另一个因素，不是吗？所以这个故事里有一件事，这个故事当然拥有一切，除了一个要素。有一个要素一直缺失。能在本系列的第三集中揭示这个要素真是太棒了。而那个要素就是一个女人。
I know. Absolute scenes. And this woman is called Sofanisba. And brilliant name and exciting person. Tell us all about Sofernisba. So she is the daughter of... of a Carthaginian general whose name, it will stun listeners to learn, is Hasdrable. Right, but of course.
我知道。绝对的场面。这个女人叫索福尼斯巴。名字很棒，人也很令人兴奋。给我们讲讲索福尼斯巴吧。她是……一位迦太基将军的女儿，听众听到这个名字会感到震惊，他叫哈斯德鲁巴。没错，当然。
I mean, basically, unless you're called Hannibal or Mago, your name is Hasrable. And he had been serving in Spain alongside Hasdrable Barker. So he was in command of one of those three armies, camped out in what was going to become Lisbon when Skippeo captured New Carthage. He's gone back to Carthage and he's become the leading figure in the Carthaginian Senate. it. And he's, now that Hasrable and Mago are both dead, he's basically the best general the Carthaginians have with the exception of Hannibal. And this isn't really to say much. So Fabius Maximus, I mean, very bitchy, described him as a general who best displayed his speed in
我的意思是，除非你叫汉尼拔或马戈，否则你的名字就是哈斯德鲁巴。他曾与哈斯德鲁巴·巴卡一起在西班牙服役。所以当西庇阿攻占新迦太基时，他指挥着那三支军队中的一支，驻扎在后来成为里斯本的地方。他回到了迦太基，并成为了迦太基元老院的领军人物。现在哈斯德鲁巴和马戈都死了，他基本上是迦太基人中除了汉尼拔之外最好的将军。但这其实说明不了什么。所以费边·马克西姆斯，我的意思是，非常刻薄地形容他是一位在撤退时最能展现其速度的将军。
retreat. So not promising. Anyway, Hasdribal has his daughter, Sophinesba. And Sofynespa is very smart, very beautiful, very, very patriotic. And Hasdrubel says to Sof and Isbba, look, it is your duty to go and marry Sifax and to get a meeting out of your hand and to make sure that he remains as a loyal ally of Carthage. And so Sophen Isba does her duty. She goes off, she marries Sifax and Sifax thinks she's absolutely great. He adores her. And so this really cements the alliance, which is obviously bad. bad news for Massinissa, because in Africa, if Sifax, with his Numidian horsemen and the mass weight of the Carthaginians in Africa, in Carthage, if they combine, Massinissa is in real trouble. So he's desperate for Scipio to arrive and provide him with the backing of the legions. And so when Scipio does land in Africa, you know, Massinista is thrilled and he feels it's payback time. And sure enough, neither hasdrubal nor Sifax prove any match for Scipio. and it turns out in fact that Scipio is prepared to play very, very dirty
所以并不令人看好。总之，哈斯德鲁巴有一个女儿，索福尼斯巴。索福尼斯巴非常聪明，非常美丽，非常非常爱国。哈斯德鲁巴对索福尼斯巴说：“看，你的职责是去嫁给西法克斯，让他听命于你，并确保他仍然是迦太基的忠实盟友。”于是索福尼斯巴履行了她的职责。她走了，嫁给了西法克斯，西法克斯认为她太棒了。他崇拜她。所以这确实巩固了联盟，这对马西尼萨来说显然是个坏消息，因为在非洲，如果西法克斯带着他的努米底亚骑兵，再加上迦太基在非洲、在迦太基的强大力量结合起来，马西尼萨就真的有大麻烦了。所以他迫切希望西庇阿到来并为他提供军团的支持。所以当西庇阿在非洲登陆时，你知道，马西尼萨很激动，他觉得是报仇的时候了。果然，无论是哈斯德鲁巴还是西法克斯，都无法与西庇阿抗衡。而且事实证明，西庇阿确实准备对西法克斯和哈斯德鲁巴玩非常非常肮脏的手段。
against Sifax and Hustrable indeed. Oh no, that's poor from Scipio. What does Scipio do that's so dirty? Well, so a few months after his arrival, he's in winter quarters, so there's no campaigning. Scipio arranges a truce with Sifax, the Numidian king,
哦不，这对西庇阿来说太糟糕了。西庇阿做了什么这么肮脏的事？嗯，在他到达几个月后，他处于冬营，所以没有军事行动。西庇阿与努米底亚国王西法克斯安排了休战，
and his goal is to try and win him back to the Roman cause because Scipio and Sifax had actually met before, Skipio had gone as an ambassador to him. And they got on well enough. Sifax said, no, I'm not interested. I love Carthage now and I've got this gorgeous wife. I'm not betraying her. Scipio then goes on, makes a personal visit to Sifax,
他的目标是试图把他拉回罗马阵营，因为西庇阿和西法克斯之前见过面，西庇阿曾作为大使去见过他。他们相处得还不错。西法克斯说：“不，我不感兴趣。我现在爱迦太基，而且我有这个漂亮的妻子。我不会背叛她。”西庇阿随后继续，对西法克斯进行了私人访问，
tries to press his case again, again, Sifax rebuffs him. But Scipio notices something interesting about Sifax's camp, and that is that all his quarters are made of reeds, So not made out of kind of earth or mud or whatever, but reeds. And then his spies come back from Hasdrables' camp, which isn't far from syphaxes, and they say, well, Hasdribal's camp, their winter quarters aren't made of mud or earth either. They are made of wood. So, Scipio ponders this.
试图再次施压，西法克斯再次拒绝了他。但西庇阿注意到西法克斯的营地有一个有趣的现象，那就是他所有的营房都是用芦苇做的，不是用土或泥什么的，而是芦苇。然后他的间谍从哈斯德鲁巴的营地回来，那个营地离西法克斯的不远，他们说，哈斯德鲁巴的营地，他们的冬营也不是用泥或土做的。它们是用木头做的。所以，西庇阿思考了这一点。
And then he intimates to Hasdribal that he might be interested in opening negotiations with him. and he floats the possibility that perhaps a peace treaty could be arrived at whereby the Romans would keep what they have in Italy and the Carthaginians could keep what they have in Africa and maybe that would be the basis for a settlement. Well, that sounds promising. That's nice. And Hasdrabel is interested in this. And so negotiations start opening between his camp and the Roman camp and Sifax gets involved as well.
然后他暗示哈斯德鲁巴，他可能有兴趣与他进行谈判。他提出了达成和平条约的可能性，即罗马人保留他们在意大利拥有的东西，迦太基人保留他们在非洲拥有的东西，也许这将是和解的基础。嗯，这听起来很有希望。这很好。哈斯德鲁巴对此很感兴趣。于是谈判开始在他的营地和罗马营地之间展开，西法克斯也参与了进来。
And so the Romans, when they send their ambassadorial teams, to these two camps are really able to scope it out. And they work out the best way to set Sifax's camp, which is made of reeds, and Hustlebo's camp, which is made of wood, on fire. Oh dear. And so, Scipio, with this information, he sends Lelius and Massenissa to torch Sifax's camp, which duly goes up, is incinerated and large numbers of Sifaxis men with them. And then he sends out another squad to set fire to the Carthaginia. camp, all the Carthaginians come rushing out, Scipio's men are on hand to slaughter them. And Polybius, he thinks this whole wheeze is absolutely brilliant.
所以罗马人在派遣大使团队到这两个营地时，确实能够进行侦察。他们想出了最好的办法，把西法克斯用芦苇做的营地和哈斯德鲁巴用木头做的营地付之一炬。哦天哪。所以，西庇阿带着这些信息，派莱利乌斯和马西尼萨去烧毁西法克斯的营地，营地如期燃起，被烧毁，大量西法克斯的人随之丧生。然后他又派出了另一支小队去放火烧迦太基人的营地，所有的迦太基人都冲了出来，西庇阿的人就在旁边屠杀他们。而波利比乌斯，他认为这个诡计绝对精彩。
So to quote him, of all Scipio's many brilliant exploits, this, it seems to me, was the most splendid and inventive. But I mean, it's blatant treachery. He's meant to be negotiating. He's broken all kinds of oaths. And it's, I think, very, very rich, considering that the Romans are endlessly going on about what they call punica feedays. So punic faith, the sense that the Carthaginians.
引用他的话：“在西庇阿众多辉煌的功绩中，这在我看来是最壮观、最有创造力的。”但我的意思是，这是公然的背信弃义。他本应是在谈判。他违反了各种誓言。而且我认为，考虑到罗马人不断地谈论他们所谓的“布匿诚信”（punica fides），即布匿人的信仰，那种认为迦太基人是独特的背信弃义者的感觉，这真是太讽刺了。
are uniquely treacherous. But don't the Romans take the view that basically is war, so the ideal thing is to kill your enemies and to win? Actually, the Romans are very anxious, as we will see, to present themselves as being on the sides of right and of the gods. So I think, I think, Skippeo is playing very, very dirty there. Anyway, I mean, it works for him. Yeah.
但罗马人不是认为本质上是战争，所以理想的事情是杀死你的敌人并获胜吗？事实上，正如我们将看到的，罗马人非常渴望表现出自己站在正义和神灵的一边。所以我认为，我认为，西庇阿在那里玩得非常非常肮脏。总之，我的意思是，这对他有效。是的。
Because he's wiped out large numbers of Carthaginian and Numidian troops. And even though Sifax and Hasdrable managed to escape the inferno, there's a sense now, I think, that Skipio clearly has the beating of them. And so it proves because the moment spring arrives he moves in for the kill. And first he meets with what
因为他消灭了大量的迦太基和努米底亚军队。尽管西法克斯和哈斯德鲁巴设法从地狱中逃脱，但我认为现在有一种感觉，西庇阿显然已经击败了他们。事实证明确实如此，因为春天一到，他就发动了致命一击。首先，他在一场战役中遇到了西法克斯和哈斯德鲁巴的残部，也就是他们的联合军队，这场战役有着极其“卡斯特式”的名字——大平原战役。所以大平原战役。你知道，西庇阿
remains to Sifax and Hasdrable so their combined army in a battle that has the brilliantly Custer-esque name of the Great Plains. So the Battle of the Great Plains. And you know, Scipio
再次展现了战术大师的风采，将他们消灭了。西法克斯和哈斯德鲁巴再次设法逃脱，但三万人留在大平原上成了秃鹫的食物。西庇阿的骑兵由马西尼萨和莱利乌斯指挥，追击西法克斯，他们俘虏了他，也俘虏了他的王后，哈斯德鲁巴美丽而爱国的女儿索福尼斯巴。她知道自己的职责。
displays tactical mastery yet again, wipes them out. Sifax and Hasdrable again managed to escape. but 30,000 are left as food for the vultures on the great plains. And Scipio's cavalry, commanded by Massenissa and Lelius, pursues Sifax, they take him prisoner, and also they take prisoner his queen, the beautiful and patriotic daughter of Hasdrubal, Sofnizba. And she knows her duty.
所以我们被告知她实际上非常像克利奥帕特拉，她非常有魅力，仅仅是看到她，仅仅是听到她说话，就会立刻被彻底迷住。所以她知道在这种情况下，西法克斯被击败了，她必须嫁给马西尼萨并试图说服他倒戈。马西尼萨被她彻底征服了。我的意思是，她显然绝对漂亮。他立即娶了她，并去找西庇阿说：“看，我有了这个伟大的新妻子，她不是很棒吗？”
So we're told that she's actually very like Cleopatra, that she was so charming that merely to see her, merely to hear her talk, was at once to be utterly smitten. And so she knows that in this situation with Sifax knocked out, she has to marry Massenissa and try and persuade him to jump ship. And Massenissa is completely swept away by her. I mean, she's clearly absolutely gorgeous. He immediately marries her and he goes to Scipio and says, look, I've got this great new wife, isn't she tremendous?
西庇阿感到震惊，因为他非常可以理解地担心索福尼斯巴会试图把马西尼萨拉到迦太基阵营。而且必须说，他不太喜欢女人。这是关于他经常被说的一点，你知道，女人被带进他的营地，他却不理会她们。就像18世纪皇家海军的一名军官，不会让女人上船，就是那种感觉。我认为非常有那种氛围。你知道，他结婚了。没错。我不认为他是一个喜欢让女士们在他营地里晃荡的人。所以他基本上告诉马西尼萨，
And Scipio is appalled because he's very understandably anxious that Sophanesbo will try and kind of win Massenissa round to the Carthaginian cause. And also, it has to be said, he's not very very much. keen on women. This is something that is often said about him, that, you know, women are kind of of introduced into his camp and he won't have anything to do with them. Like a sort of Royal Navy officer in the 18th century who won't have women on board ship, that kind of thing. Very much that vibe, I think. You know, he marries. Right. I don't think he's a great one for having ladies hanging around with him in his, in his camp. And so he essentially tells Massanissa,
“嗯，你知道，你必须在你的妻子和我之间做出选择”，而马西尼萨不是白痴。所以他选择了西庇阿。而索福尼斯巴，她一直保持着镇定和尊严，准备了一杯毒药，喝了下去。在她临死时，她责骂马西尼萨是个彻头彻尾的废物。所以这就是她的结局。这是本系列中女性的终结吗？嗯，基本上，直到她们在本系列最后都沦为奴隶。好的。
well, it's, you know, you have to choose between your wife or me, and Massanissa isn't an idiot. And so he chooses Scipio. And Sofyn Isba, who is composed and dignified to the end, prepares a cup of poison, drinks it. And as she's dying, she berates Massanissa for being absolutely useless. So that's the end of her. And is that the end of women in this series? Well, basically, until they all end up being enslaved at the very end of our series. Okay.
女性听众可以期待一下。好了。所以迦太基现在正面临绝境，对吧？完全是。西法克斯走了，哈斯德鲁巴出局了，他们基本上是在凝视深渊，而这个迦太基元老院现在别无选择，只能与罗马人进行谈判。这对他们来说一定非常痛苦。
Female listeners can look forward to that. All right. So Carthage is now staring down the barrel, right? Completely. Sifax is gone. Hasdrubal is out, they are staring into the abyss, basically, and this Carthaginian Senate have no choice now other than to open negotiations with the Romans. It must have been utterly gawning for them.
是的。所以他们派了30名大使去见西庇阿，西庇阿的条件不出所料地苛刻。所以他告诉他们，迦太基必须撤出非洲以外的所有军队。这座城市将被允许拥有20艘战舰，不能再多了。迦太基人必须在人们被送回罗马以了解元老院是否同意这些条款时，为西庇阿的军队提供补给，而且他们必须支付另一种类似于凡尔赛条约式的赔款，就像他们在上一次布匿战争结束时所做的那样。元老院非常不情愿同意这些条款，因为他们可以看出这实际上意味着他们城市作为大国地位的终结。但他们觉得他们真的别无选择。所以他们说，好吧，好吧。
Yeah. So they send 30 ambassadors to Scipio, and Scipio's terms are predictably harsh. So he tells them that Carthage will have to withdraw all her troops from lands beyond Africa. The city will be allowed 20 warships, no more than that. The Carthaginians will have to provision Skippio's army while, you know, people are sent back to Rome to find out whether the Senate agrees to these terms, and they will have to pay another kind of Versailles treaty type indemnity in the way that they'd had to do at the end of the previous Punic War. The Senate is very reluctant to agree to these terms because they can see that it effectively spells, you know, the end of their city as a great power. but they feel they haven't really got any choice. So they say, yeah, well, okay.
条款被带到了罗马，条约在那里得到了罗马元老院的批准。然而，与此同时，他们并没有完全放弃战斗，因为当然，在意大利，在意大利的脚后跟布鲁提姆，汉尼拔和他的军队仍然在那里。是的，我一直在想汉尼拔在这一切期间发生了什么。所以他只是在意大利南部闲逛。
The terms are taken to Rome, and the treaty is there ratified by the Roman Senate. Simultaneously, however, they haven't completely given up the fight because, of course, back in Italy, in Brutium, the heel of Italy, Hannibal and his army are still there. Yeah, I was wondering what had happened to Hannibal during all this. So he's just been hanging around in southern Italy.
是的，他们说：“听着，你在那里完全是在浪费时间。回到非洲，我们真的需要你。”所以他们派给他一支运输舰队，汉尼拔，我的意思是，他非常沮丧，绝对沮丧。他在那里花了这么多时间。而现在基本上他必须承认，这被浪费了。所以他带着他的军队登上了运输船，他们回到了非洲，并在一个叫莱普提斯米诺的地方登陆，那是一个港口，
Yeah, they say, listen, you're completely wasting your time there. Come back to Africa, we really need you. And so they send him a transport fleet and Hannibal, I mean, he's gutted, absolutely gutted. He spent all this time there. And now essentially he's got to recognize it. It's been wasted. So he boards the transport ships with his army and they head back to Africa and they disembark at a place called Leptis Minor, which is a port.
距离迦太基以南约100英里。他意识到，你知道，和平谈判正在进行，所以他不想打断它们。但同样，他想为最坏的情况做准备。我的意思是，假设和平谈判破裂了。所以他维持了他的军队，并在整个夏天进行了艰苦的训练。夏天变成了秋天，秋天变成了冬天。到这一点，和平条约已经在罗马由元老院批准，
about 100 miles to the south of Carthage. And he is aware that, you know, the peace negotiations are going on, so he doesn't want to interrupt them. But equally, he wants to prepare for the worst. I mean, suppose the peace negotiations break down. And so he maintains his army and he drills it very hard all that summer. And summer turns to autumn and autumn turns to winter. By this point, the peace treaty has been ratified in Rome by the Senate
并被送回迦太基，迦太基元老院必须亲自批准它。在这一点上，面对不仅失去战争，而且失去作为大帝国首都地位的前景，本质上是承认从这一点开始，他们将成为一个二流的省级大国。迦太基元老院的许多领军人物开始退缩。而且他们当然也知道，他们有汉尼拔回到了非洲土地上，而汉尼拔是他那个时代最伟大的将军。如果他们面临降级，为什么不孤注一掷，再试一次呢？绝对的。
and it is sent back to Carthage, where the Carthaginian Senate have to ratify it themselves. And at this point, faced with the prospect not just of losing the war, but of losing their status as the capital of a great empire, essentially accepting that from this point on, they're going to be a provincial second division power. lots of leading figures in the Carthaginian Senate get cold feet. And they also know, of course, that they have Hannibal back on African soil, and Hannibal is the greatest general of his day. If they're facing relegation, why not roll the dice and go for it one last time? Absolutely.
所以随着冬天变成春天，战争的第16个战役季节开始，和平显然不会维持下去，这对伟大将军的粉丝来说是巨大的，因为很明显，汉尼拔和西庇阿，这两个在整个职业生涯中从未输过一场战斗的人，他们各自城市历史上最伟大的指挥官，
And so as winter turns to spring and the 16th campaigning season of the war begins, it becomes evident that the peace is not going to hold and this is massive for fans of great generals because it's clear that Hannibal and Scipio both of the men who have never in their entire careers lost a battle the greatest commanders in the entire history of their respective cities
这两个巨人终究还是要正面交锋。我的意思是，这是一项巨大的运动。这是拿破仑和威灵顿，不是吗？这非常令人兴奋。我的意思是，有真正的紧张感。世界杯决赛即将到来。赛前紧张，是的。相当紧张。
that these two colossi are going to be going head to head after all. I mean, it's a massive sport. It's Napoleon and Wellington, isn't it? It's very exciting. I mean, there's proper tension. Sort of the World Cup final is coming. Pre-match tension, yeah. Pretty much tension.
所以，西庇阿在内陆。他从他的沿海基地向内陆移动，他正在扫荡城镇。但显然对他来说风险在于，当他扫荡城镇时，他可能会被切断与海洋的联系。汉尼拔，他需要，我的意思是，人力，军队是他的强项。他整个夏天都在训练他的新兵，尽可能多地招募军队。他有一些大象，对吧？
So, Scipio is inland. He's moved inland from his coastal base, and he is hoovering up towns. But obviously the risk for him is, as he's hoovering up towns, he might be cut off from the sea. Hannibal, he needs, I mean, manpower, troops is his thing. And he is spending the summer drilling his recruits, raising troops as many as he can. He's got some elephants, right?
80头，80头战象。我的意思是，他唯一没有的是骑兵，这很讽刺，因为骑兵一直是他最强的兵种，但他确实有这80头战象。你知道，我的意思是，他有一支强大的力量。他基本上花了整个夏天来组建一支他觉得足以对抗西庇阿和他的军团的军队，终于随着秋天的到来，他准备好了，他率领他的军队向内陆进军，前往西庇阿拥有基地的城镇附近。这个城镇，多米尼克，叫扎马。所以汉尼拔正在接近扎马。西庇阿在原地，这两位指挥官彼此靠近，他们以前从未见过面，
80, 80 war elephants. I mean, the one thing he doesn't have his cavalry, which is ironic because cavalry had always been his strongest arm, but he does have these 80 war elephants. You know, I mean, he has a serious force. And it takes him all summer, essentially, to raise an army that he feels his last. enough to take on Scipio in his legions and finally with the coming of autumn he's ready and at the head of his troops he marches inland making for the town near which Scipio has his base and this town Dominic is called Zama. So Hannibal is approaching Zama. Scipio is in situ these two commanders drawing near to each other they've never met before.
但随着他们越靠越近，很明显他们其实非常渴望见到对方。你知道，和平的试探已经发出，你知道，这样做的理由是他们将进行最后一次谈判尝试。但我认为基本上，你知道，他们都知道这不太可能导致和平条约。他们只是想见见对方。不过桌上有条款，不是吗？所以汉尼拔，例如，向西庇阿提供了一笔交易，他说：“我们可以维持现状。实际上罗马人，你知道，你可以保留西西里岛，你可以保留西班牙。”我的意思是，你知道，那是迦太基人放弃了两个巨大的奖赏。然而，迦太基将保留她的财产
but it becomes evident the nearer they come that actually they're really keen to meet with the other one. You know, peace feelers have gone out, you know, and the justification for this is that they're going to have one last attempt at negotiation. But I think basically, you know, they both know that this is very unlikely to result in a peace treaty. They just want to meet each other. There are terms on the table, though, aren't there? So Hannibal, for example, offers Scipio a deal and he says, we can preserve the status quo. effectively the Romans, you know, you can keep Sicily, you can keep Spain. I mean, you know, that's the Carthaginians giving up on two massive prizes. Carthage, however, will keep her possessions
在北非，我们不必支付巨额赔款。不会有任何形式的赔偿，我们也不会限制我们海军的规模。而西庇阿，他没有接受这一点，因为他的条款非常简单。它们是无条件投降。是的。我的意思是，他已经提供了不涉及无条件投降的条款，但现在迦太基人继续战斗，他觉得，好吧，你知道，要么投降，要么什么都没有。显然汉尼拔的条款对西庇阿来说是不可接受的，而西庇阿的条款对汉尼拔来说是不可接受的。于是会面结束了，不会再有谈判了。因此，战斗现在不可避免。
in North Africa and we won't have to pay a big indemnity. There'll be no kind of reparations, and we won't have a limit on the size of our Navy. And Scipio, he is not taking that because his terms are very simple. They are unconditional surrender. Yeah. I mean, he'd already offered terms that didn't involve unconditional surrender, but now the Carthaginians carrying on the fight, he feels, well, you know, it's surrender or nothing. And clearly Hannibal's terms are unacceptable to Skipio, and Skipio's terms are unacceptable to Hanibal. And so the interview comes to an end, there will be no more negotiations. Consequently, battle is now inevitable.
这意味着这个时代最伟大的两位指挥官即将在一场终极的泰坦之战中相遇。好吧，我们喜欢在《历史的其余部分》中看到泰坦之战。休息后回来，扎马战役就开始了。使用美国运通白金卡，您可以进入全球1400多个机场贵宾室。所以您起飞前的体验就是未来体验的缩影。这就是美国运通的强大支持。条件适用。加拿大各地的本地新闻正在衰落，这对我们所有人来说都是坏消息。
And this means that the two greatest commanders of the age are about to meet in the ultimate clash of Titans. Well, we love a clash of the Titans on the rest is history. Come back after the break and the battle of Zama begins. With Amex Platinum, you have access to over 1,400 airport lounges worldwide. So your experience before takeoff is a taste of what's to come. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Conditions apply. Local news is in decline across Canada, and this is bad news for all of us.
随着本地新闻的减少，噪音、谣言和错误信息填补了空白。区分事实与虚构变得越来越难。这就是为什么加拿大广播公司新闻部（CBC News）正在加拿大各地投入更多的记者，在您居住的地方进行实地报道，讲述对我们所有人重要的事情。因为本地新闻就是大新闻。选择新闻，而不是噪音。加拿大广播公司新闻部。大家好。
With less local news, noise, rumors, and misinformation fill the void. And it gets harder to separate truth from fiction. That's why CBC News is putting more journalists in more places across Canada, reporting on the ground from where you live, telling the stories that matter to all of us. Because local news is big news. Choose news, not noise. CBC News. Hello, everyone.
我带着一些极其令人兴奋的消息来到这里。现在，正如我们所有亲爱的俱乐部成员已经知道的那样，成为“历史的其余部分”俱乐部成员最好的事情之一就是可以访问独家会员专享的迷你剧集。没错。迷你剧集，不仅仅是单独的剧集。所以这些是每隔一个月一次的特别剧集，只有俱乐部成员才能收听。没有其他人。我们将在今年二月推出一个全新的剧集。所以这将是2026年的第一个剧集，由我和伟大的艺术评论家劳拉·卡明共同呈现，共四集，它是关于那些以特别迷人的方式照亮历史的画作，它涵盖了广泛的时间和地点。所以从委拉斯开兹的《宫娥》，被许多评论家描述为最伟大的画作，一直到亨利·雷伯恩的《滑冰的牧师》。这些画作告诉我们关于它们被创作时的时代什么？这真的，真的
I am here with some exceedingly exciting news. Now, as all our beloved club members will already know, one of the very best things of being a member of the rest of history club is getting access to exclusive members only miniseries. That's right. Miniseries, not just individual episodes. So these are special episodes every other month, which only club members can listen to. No one else. And we've got a brand new one coming out this February. So that's going to be the the very first one of 2026, and it is presented by me and the great art critic Laura Cumming, four episodes, and it's about paintings that shed a particularly fascinating light on history, and it covers a broad range of times and places. So everything from Velasquez's Las Meninas, described by many critics as the greatest of all paintings, right the way up to Henry Rayburn's Skating Minister. what do these paintings tell us about the times in which they were painted? It's really, really
我带来了一些非常令人兴奋的消息。现在，正如我们所有亲爱的俱乐部成员所知，成为“历史俱乐部”成员最棒的事情之一，就是可以收听仅限会员的独家迷你系列节目。没错，是迷你系列，而不仅仅是单集。这些是每隔一个月推出的特别节目，只有俱乐部成员才能收听，其他人无法收听。我们二月份将推出一个全新的系列，这将是2026年的第一个系列。它由我和伟大的艺术评论家劳拉·卡明共同主持，共四集，内容是关于那些以特别迷人的方式揭示历史的画作，涵盖了广泛的时间和地点。从许多评论家描述为“最伟大画作”的委拉斯开兹的《宫娥》，一直到亨利·雷伯恩的《滑冰牧师》。这些画作向我们揭示了它们创作时代的哪些信息？这真的非常非常
fascinating stuff. And if you are not watching it on YouTube or Spotify, if you're just listening to it as a podcast, don't worry because we will be sending all our members an email, which will be going into greater written detail about the painting, but also obviously giving you an image of the painting itself. So you can have a quick look at that, perhaps before you listen to the episode. Although I have to say that Laura's descriptions of each painting are so. good that perhaps you don't even need to look at the painting. So if you would like to sign up to that miniseries and to the other five miniseries that we will be doing this year, which will be covering everything from history's greatest photographs, the Vietnam War, to England's
非常精彩的内容。如果您不是在YouTube或Spotify上观看，而只是在收听播客，请不必担心，因为我们会给所有会员发送一封电子邮件，其中会详细介绍这幅画作的文字内容，当然也会附上画作本身的图片。这样您可以在收听本集之前先快速浏览一下。尽管我必须说，劳拉对每一幅画的描述都非常出色，以至于您可能根本不需要看画。所以，如果您想订阅这个迷你系列以及我们今年将要制作的其他五个迷你系列，涵盖从历史上最伟大的照片、越南战争到英国的各个方面，
she-wolves, then you know where to go. Go to the rest ishistory.com if you are not already a club member and sign up there. Welcome back, everybody, to The Rest is History. Now we promised you the Titanic showdown between Hannibal and Scipio. This is the moment towards which not just this series, but our previous series about Rome and Carthage have been building. So Tom, we don't have all day. So let's just get into the highlights. Take us through the highlights of this Titanic clash.
母狼，那么您知道该去哪里。如果您还不是俱乐部会员，请前往therestishistory.com注册。欢迎大家回到《历史的余味》。现在，我们承诺过要为您讲述汉尼拔与西庇阿之间的泰坦尼克式对决。这是不仅本系列，而且我们之前关于罗马和迦太基的系列一直在铺垫的时刻。所以汤姆，我们时间有限，让我们直接进入高潮部分。带我们了解一下这场泰坦尼克式冲突的精彩片段吧。
Okay. So as we said, Hannibal for the first time is weak in cavalry. So he's therefore weak on his wings. Skipio, by contrast, has excellent cavalry. He has his own. We've mentioned them before, the best trained cavalry of the Romans have ever had. And of course, he has Massenissa's Numidians, even though they almost miss the battle because Massenissa turns up very late.
好的。正如我们所说，汉尼拔的骑兵首次处于弱势。因此，他的侧翼力量薄弱。相比之下，西庇阿拥有出色的骑兵。他拥有自己的骑兵，我们之前提到过，这是罗马人有史以来训练最精良的骑兵。当然，他还有马西尼萨的努米底亚骑兵，尽管他们差点错过这场战斗，因为马西尼萨出现得非常晚。
So Lelius is in command of the Roman cavalry. Massanissa is in command of his Numidians, and they meet with the Carthaginian cavalry, route them and chase them from the battlefield. Now, Hannibal's strength, as we've said, is in his war elephants, and he places them in the front line, 80 of them. Terrifying sight. The Roman front lines, you know, they're kind of quaking in their sandals. But Scipio has prepared for this onslaught. And again, remember, the infantry, like the cavalry, are very, very well drilled, much better drilled than any Roman army before them in history. And so when the elephants charged them, they essentially step aside and open a
所以莱利乌斯指挥罗马骑兵，马西尼萨指挥他的努米底亚骑兵，他们迎战迦太基骑兵，将其击溃并从战场上驱逐。现在，正如我们所说，汉尼拔的优势在于他的战象，他将80头战象部署在前线。景象非常恐怖。罗马前线的士兵们，你知道，他们的腿都在发抖。但西庇阿已经为这次猛攻做好了准备。再次提醒，步兵和骑兵一样，训练非常非常精良，比历史上任何之前的罗马军队都要好。所以当战象冲向他们时，他们实际上是侧身闪开，打开了
up corridors down which the elephants just go rampaging. And they kind of burst out at the other side and they can be kind of easily tracked down and eliminated that way. So that's Hannibal's strongest card played and it hasn't worked. And so what now happens is that it comes down to the infantry, these great rival blocks of men on foot and they advance and they smash into each other. And to quote Polybius, many fell on both sides, fighting with fierce determination where they stood. But at length the squadrons of Massinissa and of Lelius returned from their pursuit of the Carthaginian cavalry and arrived by a stroke of fortune at the crucial moment. And the result, Dominic, listeners, is that Scipio is able to inflict on Hannibal the kind of wipeout that he had
一条条通道，让战象从中间横冲直撞过去。它们从另一端冲出，这样就很容易被追踪并消灭。所以汉尼拔最强的一张牌打出去了，但没起作用。现在发生的情况是，战斗演变成了步兵之间的较量，这些伟大的敌对步兵方阵相互冲撞。引用波利比乌斯的话：“双方伤亡惨重，在各自的位置上顽强战斗。”但最终，马西尼萨和莱利乌斯的骑兵中队在追击迦太基骑兵后返回，并在关键时刻奇迹般地赶到。多米尼克，听众朋友们，结果就是西庇阿能够对汉尼拔造成那种他曾经
so often inflicted on the Romans. The irony of it. Yeah, the irony. And Hannibal himself takes horse, he manages to flee the disaster, but according to Polybius, 20,000 of Hannibal's men are left dead on the battlefield and the same number are taken prisoner and the Romans, by contrast, lost only 1,500 men. And again, to quote Polybius, this was the result of the final battle between these two commanders and it decided the war. Crikey, so what a turnaround from the battles of late Trasamine or can I. And a question for you, is there a world in which the Battle of Zama goes differently? Or do the Roman institutional advantages at this point, do they outweigh the Carthaginian strong points so heavily that there's basically no way Hannibal can win this battle? I mean,
经常对罗马人造成的毁灭性打击。真是讽刺。是的，讽刺。汉尼拔本人骑马逃离了灾难，但据波利比乌斯记载，汉尼拔有2万名士兵战死沙场，同样数量的人被俘，而罗马人相比之下只损失了1500人。再次引用波利比乌斯的话，这是这两位指挥官之间最后一场战斗的结果，它决定了战争的胜负。天哪，这与特拉西梅诺湖或坎尼战役相比真是巨大的转折。我有一个问题，是否存在一种可能，扎马战役的结果会不同？还是说罗马在这一点的制度优势已经超过了迦太基的强项，以至于汉尼拔根本无法赢得这场战斗？我的意思是，
anything can happen in a battle, right? Against a less competent commander and against less well-trained troops, you can imagine Hannibal winning. But it's clear that the effects of the fighting over, you know, these decade and more, has been to hone the Roman army into a much more lethal killing machine than had been at the start of the war. They're much better drilled. They have the gladius now, this stabbing sword that they've borrowed from the Spaniards. It makes their infantry superb. But the other factor, I think, which dooms Hannibal in this battle, is, as we said, he doesn't have cavalry. And Hannibal's great genius has always been for coordinating infantry and cavalry.
战场上什么都可能发生，对吧？面对能力较弱的指挥官和训练较差的部队，你可以想象汉尼拔会获胜。但很明显，经过这十年多的战斗，罗马军队已经被磨练成了一台比战争初期更致命的杀戮机器。他们训练得更好。他们现在有了从西班牙人那里借来的格拉迪乌斯短剑，这使得他们的步兵非常出色。但我认为导致汉尼拔在这场战斗中注定失败的另一个因素是，正如我们所说，他没有骑兵。而汉尼拔伟大的天才一直在于协调步兵和骑兵。
Yeah. And it just doesn't work. And the one card he really had his elephants, the Romans know how to deal with them. They're frightening, but they know how to cope with them. How much do those factors, so the extraordinary preparedness and proficiency of the Roman infantry, but also the Carthaginian lack of cavalry, how much do they reflect a deeper issue, which is Rome's institutional resources compared with Carthagos, economic
是的。但这根本行不通。他唯一的一张牌——他的战象，罗马人知道如何对付。它们虽然可怕，但罗马人知道如何应对。这些因素，即罗马步兵非凡的准备和熟练程度，以及迦太基缺乏骑兵，在多大程度上反映了一个更深层次的问题，即罗马与迦太基相比的制度资源，经济
resources, manpower and so on? I mean, absolutely, because Rome's great sense. strength throughout has been her manpower. And Carthage has always opted to rely on mercenaries. So it's that classic thing where basically you can lose and lose and lose, but one day if you win, you win the whole thing. Yeah. If you're the bigger power. Essentially. And by this point, Rome is indisputed with bigger power because over the course of the war, she has occupied the whole of Sicily. And Spain, of course. Yeah. And she's in the process of conquering the road that joins Spain to Italy, which will become the Provincia or Provence, as it's
资源、人力等等？我的意思是，绝对是这样，因为罗马一直以来的巨大优势在于她的人力。而迦太基一直选择依赖雇佣兵。所以这是一个经典的情况，基本上你可以输了一次又一次，但只要有一天你赢了，你就赢得了全部。是的。如果你是更大的势力。本质上是这样。到目前为止，罗马无疑是更强大的势力，因为在战争过程中，她已经占领了整个西西里岛。当然还有西班牙。是的。而且她正在征服连接西班牙和意大利的道路，这条道路将成为普罗旺斯省，正如它
still cool to this day. So Southern France, Southern Gaul. So the Carthaginians have rolled the dice. Hannibal has gambled and he has lost. And the result of this, I mean, they probably thought, well, we have nothing to lose. But they do. But now they discover precisely what they do have to lose because Scipio's terms when they return to the negotiating table are that much harsher, precisely because the Carthaginians didn't agree immediately. So the indemnity is going to be even bigger. And what is more, it's going to be paid over 50 years. So that is a deliberate policy. of tying the Carthaginians down, crippling their economy for half a century.
至今仍被称为的那样。所以是法国南部，高卢南部。迦太基人掷下了骰子。汉尼拔赌了一把，但他输了。结果就是，我的意思是，他们可能认为，好吧，我们没什么可失去的。但他们确实有。但现在他们发现了他们到底有什么可失去的，因为西庇阿在他们回到谈判桌时提出的条件要严苛得多，正是因为迦太基人没有立即同意。所以赔款会更多。而且更重要的是，它将在50年内付清。所以这是一个蓄意的政策，
They cannot go to war without explicit Roman permission. So that essentially means that the Romans have now taken over Carthagin's foreign policy. And previously they'd been permitted 20 warships. Now they can only have 10. But the guy who is laughing, I mean, the guy who's really come out well from this, of course, is Massinissa, the Numidian king.
旨在束缚迦太基人，在半个世纪内摧毁他们的经济。他们未经罗马明确许可不得发动战争。所以这基本上意味着罗马现在已经接管了迦太基的外交政策。以前他们被允许拥有20艘战舰。现在他们只能拥有10艘。但那个笑到最后的人，我的意思是，那个真正从中获益的人，当然是努米底亚国王马西尼萨。
and Scipio confirms him as king not just over his own tribal federation, but over Sifax's Namedians as well. And I think even more faithfully, and whether this was a deliberate policy to create trouble or not, it's unclear, but I mean it definitely will create trouble. The peace terms imposed on the Carthaginians obliged them, and I quote, to restore to Massanissa all the houses, territory, cities and other property which had belonged to him or to his ancestors. So effectively, this is to leave Carthage with its own hinterland. But what the borders are between that hinterland and Numidia is very unclear.
西庇阿确认他不仅是自己部落联盟的国王，也是西法克斯努米底亚人的国王。我认为更具决定性的是，无论这是否是制造麻烦的蓄意政策，虽然不清楚，但这肯定会制造麻烦。强加给迦太基人的和平条款要求他们，我引用：“归还马西尼萨所有属于他或他祖先的房屋、领土、城市和其他财产。”所以实际上，这是要让迦太基保留自己的腹地。但那个腹地与努米底亚之间的边界非常不明确。
And, you know, Massanessa will obviously have one point. The Carthaginians will have another. Massanissa is an ally of Rome. The Carthaginians are not allowed to go to war without Roman permission. You can see that it is, you know, this is going to be a sea of troubles for the Carthaginians. Yeah, and it will give Massinissa all kinds of opportunities, right? It's for bad behaviour in the future. So there are a lot of Carthaginians, presumably when these terms come in, even now after
而且，你知道，马西尼萨显然会有他的观点。迦太基人会有另一个观点。马西尼萨是罗马的盟友。迦太基人未经罗马许可不得发动战争。你可以看出，这对于迦太基人来说将是一片麻烦的海洋。是的，这会给马西尼萨提供各种机会，对吧？在未来进行不良行为。所以有很多迦太基人，大概当这些条款出来时，即使现在在
their defeat at Zama, they must still be thinking, God, is there anything we can do to avoid signing up to this? You know, rather like, I mean, the obvious comparison is Germany at the end of the First World War, right? I mean, that's the shadow that's hanging over this whole story. Or Hitler in the bunker. Right. Could you go down in flames?
他们在扎马战败后，一定还在想，天哪，我们有什么办法可以避免签署这个协议吗？你知道，就像，明显的比较是第一次世界大战结束时的德国，对吧？我的意思是，那是笼罩在这个故事上的阴影。或者地堡里的希特勒。对。你能就这样在火焰中毁灭吗？
Yeah, it's that bad. And there is actually a Carthaginian senator called Gisco who stands up and makes this case to a public assembly. But Hannibal hears him, and he is infuriated, and he physically hauls Gisco down from the roster and where he's standing with his own hands. And this is not acceptable behavior at all, and so everyone is very cross with him.
是的，情况就是那么糟糕。实际上有一位名叫吉斯科的迦太基参议员站出来向公众集会陈述了这一点。但汉尼拔听到了，他被激怒了，他亲手把吉斯科从他站立的讲台上拽了下来。这根本是不可接受的行为，所以每个人都对他非常生气。
And Hannibal apologizes very gracefully, and he says, look, I haven't been in the city since I was nine or whatever. I've been living in an army camp all these decades. My manners are very rough and ready. So I do apologise. However, he then goes on to say, Gisco is mad if he thinks that these terms from Scipio are bad. They could have been much, much worse.
汉尼拔非常优雅地道歉了，他说，看，我从九岁起就没在城里待过。这几十年来我一直住在军营里。我的举止非常粗鲁。所以我道歉。然而，他接着说，如果吉斯科认为西庇阿的这些条款很糟糕，那他就是疯了。情况本可能更糟得多。
And he says, you know, we will still be governing ourselves. There will not be a Roman garrison planted in the middle of our city. We still have, you know, our hinterland. and that hinterland is very rich and prosperous and fertile. And he says he makes an appeal to the Carthaginian people. I beg you, not even to debate the matter. Instead, pray with one single voice that the Roman people will ratify Scipio's terms. And of course, Hannibal is the great enemy of Rome.
他说，你知道，我们仍然会自我管理。不会有罗马驻军驻扎在我们城市的中心。我们仍然拥有，你知道，我们的腹地。而且那个腹地非常富饶、繁荣和肥沃。他说他向迦太基人民呼吁。我恳求你们，甚至不要辩论这件事。相反，用同一个声音祈祷罗马人民批准西庇阿的条款。当然，汉尼拔是罗马的死敌。
He is the man who, you know, year after year after year has been in the front line fighting the Romans. And for him now to say we have to make peace means that there can really be no arguing with the case that he's making. Yeah, of course. If the guy who's the hero of the Carthaginian cause is saying, let's do a deal, they're clearly going to do a deal. And so in the long run, they do.
他是那个，你知道，年复一年在前线与罗马人作战的人。现在他站出来说我们必须讲和，这意味着他提出的理由真的无可辩驳。是的，当然。如果作为迦太基事业英雄的人都在说，让我们达成协议吧，他们显然会达成协议。所以从长远来看，他们确实做到了。
The Carthaginians agree. Scipio in Rome gets approval from the Senate for his treaty. And at last, I mean, this great war, I mean, capital G, capital W, a war that has gone on for almost 20 years, it is over. and actually this is kind of the end for both Hannibal and Skippio as well
迦太基人同意了。西庇阿在罗马获得了参议院对其条约的批准。终于，我的意思是，这场伟大的战争，大写的W，一场持续了近20年的战争，结束了。实际上，这对汉尼拔和西庇阿来说也是一种终结，
because their time in the sun, the opportunity to shine has now been taken away. It's certainly the end of their military careers. Neither of them will command armies ever again. But Hannibal, I mean, he remains the dominating figure in the Carthaginian state. and he actually proves very impressive as a civilian leader. He streamlines the finances in Carthage. There's kind of endless fraud embezzlement and so on, and he appreciates that Carthage is going to need every last bit of coin
因为他们辉煌的时代，闪耀的机会现在已经被剥夺了。这无疑是他们军事生涯的终结。他们两人都不会再指挥军队了。但汉尼拔，我的意思是，他仍然是迦太基国家的主导人物。而且他实际上证明了自己作为文职领导人非常出色。他精简了迦太基的财政。那里有无尽的欺诈、贪污等等，他意识到迦太基将需要每一分钱
that it can scrounge together. And he also democratises the Carthaginian government. So he is essentially a populist. He's not popular with his fellow Carthaginian aristocrats, but he's very, very popular with the mass of the Carthaginian government. people. And so he introduces reforms that are designed to weaken the hold of the Carthaginian aristocracy on the justice system. And Simon Hornblower, a great ancient historian, author of a brilliant dual biography of Hannibal and Scipio, describes it as an energetic left-wing
它能搜刮到的钱。他还使迦太基政府民主化。所以他本质上是一个民粹主义者。他不受迦太基贵族同僚的欢迎，但他非常、非常受迦太基广大民众的欢迎。因此，他推行了旨在削弱迦太基贵族对司法系统控制的改革。西蒙·霍恩布洛尔，一位伟大的古代历史学家，一本关于汉尼拔和西庇阿的精彩双传记的作者，将其描述为一位充满活力的左翼
innovator. Left-wing innovator. The Tony Ben of Carthaginian history. I mean, obviously, this means that loads of his fellow senators have even more reason now to loathe him. I mean, not only are they jealous of him, but they're resentful of him that he's kind of trying to undermine their power. But, you know, he remains massively popular with the Carthaginian people. And so for now, Hannibal seems safe enough. Something quite American about Hannibal, I think. The Americans love electing generals as presidents.
创新者。左翼创新者。迦太基历史上的托尼·本。我的意思是，显然，这意味着他的一大批参议员同僚现在更有理由憎恨他了。我的意思是，他们不仅嫉妒他，而且对他试图削弱他们的权力感到愤恨。但是，你知道，他在迦太基人民中仍然非常受欢迎。所以目前，汉尼拔似乎还算安全。我觉得汉尼拔身上有一种非常美国化的特质。美国人喜欢选举将军担任总统。
And he has returned from the war. Okay, he hasn't won. I mean, so he's an American general who's been serving in Vietnam. But he has returned with his luster undimmed, I guess, for the ordinary Carthaginians. And what about Scipio? So, Scipio surely must now sort of glitter as the greatest here in the Roman pantheon. He's trailing clouds of glory. And he is given a stupefying succession of honours.
他从战争中归来。好吧，他没有赢。我的意思是，所以他是一位曾在越南服役的美国将军。但他带着光环归来，我想，对于普通迦太基人来说，他的光芒并未减弱。那西庇阿呢？所以，西庇阿现在肯定被视为罗马万神殿中最伟大的英雄。他带着荣耀的光环。他被授予了一连串令人目瞪口呆的荣誉。
So he's given a triumph. Interesting that he doesn't insist that Hannibal walks in that triumph. It reflects the fact that... Scipio continues to respect Hannibal and that treating Hannibal with respect in a way burnishes his own glory. Because if you humiliate Hannibal, then in a sense you're downgrading him as an enemy. So I think that's probably what's been going on in Scipio's mind. Anyway, he has his triumph. He's awarded Fabius by this point is dead.
所以他获得了凯旋式。有趣的是，他没有坚持让汉尼拔在那场凯旋式中游行。这反映了这样一个事实……西庇阿继续尊重汉尼拔，并且以某种方式尊重汉尼拔反而增添了他自己的荣耀。因为如果你羞辱汉尼拔，那么在某种意义上，你是在贬低他作为敌人的价值。所以我认为这可能就是西庇阿脑子里在想的事情。无论如何，他举行了凯旋式。他被授予了法比乌斯此时已经去世。
So the title of Prinkeptanatus, chief senator, is vacant. So Scipio takes it. And he's given the title of Afrikanus. So Scipio the African, meaning that he has essentially defeated. the Africans and Livy notes that he was the first general in Rome to be celebrated by the name of the people he had conquered. So, Skippio Afrikanus, I mean, he's clearly a massive, dominating, glamorous, prestigious figure. But it's interesting that he seems to have adjusted less successfully to civilian life than Hannibal. And we've been comparing him on and off throughout this
所以首席参议员的头衔空缺了。于是西庇阿接任了。他被授予了“阿非利加努斯”的头衔。所以西庇阿·阿非利加努斯，意味着他基本上击败了非洲人。李维指出，他是罗马第一位以他所征服的人民的名字来庆祝的将军。所以，西庇阿·阿非利加努斯，我的意思是，他显然是一个巨大的、主导的、迷人的、享有盛誉的人物。但有趣的是，他似乎比汉尼拔更难适应平民生活。我们一直在比较他，断断续续地贯穿了这一集
episode in the previous one to the Duke of Wellington, who fought a war in Spain and then met with the greatest enemy of his country and defeated him in a climactic battle that ended that enemy's career. So you could think of Zama as the, you know, the Waterloo of the Punei Wars. And then like the Duke of Wellington, who became Prime Minister and was a terrible prime minister, Scipio finds it hard to take the Senate with him. So there's this brilliant thing, isn't there, of the Duke of Wellington, has his first cabinet meeting and is outraged. He says, I gave them their orders, but they wanted to stay behind and discuss them. And I think there's a similar feeling with, with Scipio.
和上一集，与威灵顿公爵相比，他在西班牙打了一场战争，然后遇到了他国家最大的敌人，并在决定性的战斗中击败了他，结束了那个敌人的职业生涯。所以你可以把扎马战役看作是，你知道，布匿战争的滑铁卢。然后像威灵顿公爵一样，他成为了首相，却是一个糟糕的首相，西庇阿发现很难让参议院支持他。所以有这样一件精彩的事情，不是吗，威灵顿公爵，他召开了第一次内阁会议，结果被激怒了。他说，我给了他们命令，但他们却想留下来讨论它们。我想西庇阿也有类似的感觉。
Yeah. You know, he's got his long hair. He's very glamorous. He's, you know, son of a snake. He can't be bothered with senators sitting on their dignity. Talking about drainage. Talking about, well, I mean, probably moaning about him. Right.
是的。你知道，他留着长发。他非常有魅力。他，你知道，是蛇的儿子。他无法忍受参议员们坐在那里摆架子。谈论排水系统。谈论，好吧，我的意思是，可能是在抱怨他。对。
And I think, you know, the very range of honors that he's got, you know, his titles, Prinkeps, imperator. They generate jealousy, I think. And there is one person in particular who really detests him. And this is a guy we met traveling with the Roman fleet to Africa from Sicily. And this is the erstwhile Quister, the paymaster in Scipio's army, M. Porzius Cato, this man who was Scipio's opposite in every way. And to quote one of his later biographers, as Scipio's Quister during the war in Africa, Cato was appalled by Scipio's habitual extravagance and how ready he was to lavish money on his soldiers
我认为，你知道，他获得的荣誉范围，你知道，他的头衔，首席参议员，统帅。我认为它们引发了嫉妒。有一个人特别憎恨他。这就是我们遇到的一位随罗马舰队从西西里前往非洲的人。这就是曾经的财务官，西庇阿军队的财务主管，M·波尔基乌斯·加图，这个人在各方面都与西庇阿截然相反。引用他后来的一位传记作者的话，作为西庇阿在非洲战争期间的财务官，加图对西庇阿习惯性的奢侈以及他准备在士兵身上挥霍金钱的态度感到震惊
and he's appalled both because it's a waste of money which Cato doesn't approve of but also because I think the sense that perhaps Scipio is buying the favour of his soldiers and again Cato is very very disapproving of this We talked about his slightly performative but no doubt deep-seated and heartfelt conservatism so when they return in the years after the Battle of Zama
他感到震惊，既是因为这是一种浪费金钱的行为，加图不赞成，也是因为我认为他感觉到西庇阿可能是在收买士兵的忠诚，加图对此非常、非常不赞成。我们谈到了他那种略带表演性质但无疑是根深蒂固且发自内心的保守主义，所以当他们在扎马战役后的几年里回来时
like Cato turns himself, doesn't he, into the champion of the Conservatives. He doesn't take bribes. He lives very austerely. He, for example, sets his heart against legislation that would allow women to wear jewelry in public. Yeah, so it's good to have women back on the show,
加图把自己变成了保守派的捍卫者，不是吗？他不收受贿赂，生活极其简朴。例如，他坚决反对允许女性在公共场合佩戴珠宝的立法。是的，所以很高兴节目里又有女性嘉宾了，
isn't it? Yeah, brilliant for them. Plutarch tells us that Cato despised philosophy and as a patriot was thoroughly contemptuous of Greek culture and lifestyle, so he doesn't even use doctors. No, because doctors are Greek, and both his wife and his children then die,
不是吗？是的，这对她们来说太棒了。普鲁塔克告诉我们，加图鄙视哲学，作为一名爱国者，他彻底蔑视希腊文化和生活方式，所以他甚至不看医生。不，因为医生是希腊人，结果他的妻子和孩子都因此去世了，
but Cato's unapologetic. He'd rather have them dead than use a Greek doctor. Right, exactly. And I guess, you know, we compared Scipio with Alexander. That aspect of Scipio's personality, the populism, the showiness, the charisma is precisely what Cato despises as un-Roman. So when Cato is campaigning,
但加图毫无悔意。他宁愿让他们死也不愿找希腊医生。没错，正是如此。我想，我们把西庇阿和亚历山大做了比较。西庇阿个性的那一面——民粹主义、炫耀和魅力——正是加图所鄙视的“非罗马”特质。所以当加图在竞选时，
you know, he shares the rations of the men, he wears the kind of fatigues, he carries his own armour, You know, he is very different from the kind of glamour boy style that Scipio incarnates. Yeah. And actually, their enmity is going to become one of the great drivers of Roman politics in this period. So, Scipio has been in charge of a campaign in Spain where he's been doing all this, you know, carrying his own armour and stuff.
你知道，他与士兵们同吃口粮，穿着那种作战服，自己背着盔甲。你知道，他与西庇阿所体现的那种魅力男孩风格截然不同。是的。实际上，他们的敌对关系将成为这一时期罗马政治的主要驱动力之一。所以，西庇阿一直在西班牙负责一场战役，在那里他一直在做这些事，你知道，自己背着盔甲之类的。
And it's very successful. And when he returns to Roman 194, he is awarded a triumph. And I think that he feels, well, I've made my name now. and he's ready to bring his enmity with Scipio out into the open. And so this means that Scipio now has a rival who can kind of provide a counterweight to Scipio's prestige in the Senate. Something else that is slightly putting Scipio's luster into shade is developments in the eastern Mediterranean,
而且非常成功。当他在公元前194年回到罗马时，他被授予了凯旋式。我想他觉得，好吧，我现在已经名扬天下了。他准备把与西庇阿的敌对关系公开化。这意味着西庇阿现在有了一个对手，可以在元老院中作为西庇阿声望的制衡力量。还有一件事让西庇阿的光芒稍微黯淡了一些，那就是东地中海的事态发展，
which we have not yet talked about in this series, but there very dramatic developments have taken place. Because as we've already mentioned, Rome has finished the Great War against Hannibal with what is probably the most lethal and battle-hardened fighting force in the whole of history. And if you have the most lethal and battle-hardened fighting force in history, very tempting to use it. Right. I mean, why let it go to waste?
我们在本系列中还没有谈到这一点，但那里发生了非常戏剧性的变化。因为正如我们之前提到的，罗马以历史上最致命、最久经沙场的战斗力量结束了与汉尼拔的大战。如果你拥有历史上最致命、最久经沙场的战斗力量，那么使用它就非常有诱惑力。没错。我的意思是，为什么要浪费它呢？
Yeah, of course. And Carthage obviously remains Rome's, you know, the chief object of her vigilance. But she is not in any mood to take insubordination from other famous powers either. So in Macedon, on the other side of the Adriatic, what's now northern Greece, there is a king there who sits on what had once been the throne of Alexander the Great. And this is a guy who's been Macedonian king for many decades, Philip V. and in the course of the Punic War he had made a terrible mistake because he had assumed in the immediate wake of the Battle of Cannae
是的，当然。迦太基显然仍然是罗马警惕的主要对象。但罗马也不打算容忍其他著名强权的任何不服从。所以在亚得里亚海的另一边，也就是现在的希腊北部，马其顿有一位国王，他坐在曾经属于亚历山大的宝座上。这就是已经担任马其顿国王几十年的腓力五世。在布匿战争期间，他犯了一个可怕的错误，因为他在坎尼会战后立即认为
that Rome was bound to lose and so he had signed up to an alliance with Hannibal didn't actually go anywhere but the Romans in their kind of best mafia style do not forget this show of disrespect and so in the year 200 So very shortly after the Battle of Zama, a Roman task force crosses the Adriatic, begins a war against Macedon. And in 197, the legions meet with Philip's great phalanx, this great kind of bristling porcupine of spears at a battle at a place called kinacephali.
罗马注定会失败，所以他与汉尼拔结成了联盟。虽然实际上并没有什么进展，但罗马人以他们那种典型的黑手党风格，并没有忘记这种不敬。因此在公元前200年，也就是扎马战役后不久，一支罗马特遣部队越过亚得里亚海，开始了对马其顿的战争。公元前197年，罗马军团在基诺斯克法莱的一个地方，与腓力那支像豪猪一样长矛林立的伟大方阵相遇。
And the Romans cut the Macedonian phalanx to pieces. And the guy who has won that victory, a man called Flaminius, the following year, He goes to the Isthmian games, which are held in Corinth, the city that, you know, on the kind of the join point between northern Greece and the Peloponnese. And there he proclaims the freedom of the Greeks in flamboyant language. At the same time, with a kind of completely unembarrassed hypocrisy, which will become very, very typical of Roman behavior over the succeeding decades. He also replaces the Macedonian garrisons that had been a very typical. occupying various strongholds in Greece, in which were colloquially known as the fetters of Greece with Roman garrisons. So even as he is proclaiming the fact that I've defeated Macedon, I've
罗马人将马其顿方阵切成了碎片。赢得这场胜利的人，一个叫弗拉米尼努斯的人，在第二年去了科林斯举行的地峡运动会，科林斯就是那个位于希腊北部和伯罗奔尼撒半岛连接处的城市。在那里，他用华丽的语言宣布了希腊人的自由。与此同时，带着一种完全不加掩饰的虚伪——这种虚伪在随后的几十年里将成为罗马行为的典型——他还用罗马驻军取代了马其顿驻军，这些马其顿驻军曾长期驻扎在希腊的各个据点，被俗称为“希腊的枷锁”。所以，即使在他宣布我击败了马其顿，我
freed Greece for a Macedonian tyranny. Greece is now free. He is replacing those Macedonian garrisons with Roman garrisons. And it means that Greece is now effectively, within less than a decade of the Battle of Zama, it's become a Roman protectorate. So listeners may be wondering, so much of this story has been about the Western Mediterranean. What's been going on in the Eastern Mediterranean. And the answer is in the previous 120 years, or so, Alexander the Great Empire, covering some of the richest parts of the kind of classical world, had broken up into different competing kingdoms ruled by the so-called successes, so the descendants of his captains and lieutenants. You can almost think of them as lots of different Greek-run or Macedonian-run
从马其顿暴政下解放了希腊。希腊现在自由了。他却在用罗马驻军取代那些马其顿驻军。这意味着在扎马战役不到十年内，希腊实际上已经成为了罗马的保护国。所以听众可能想知道，这个故事的很大一部分是关于西地中海的。东地中海发生了什么？答案是，在过去大约120年里，亚历山大大帝的帝国，覆盖了古典世界最富饶的一些地区，已经分裂成不同的竞争王国，由所谓的“继业者”统治，也就是他那些将军和副官的后代。你可以把它们看作是许多不同的希腊人或马其顿人统治的
kingdoms. And there are other Macedonian kingdoms, obviously Ptolemaic Egypt is one. Yeah, so there are basically three. So there's Macedon, which governs Greece, but have now been defeated by the Romans. The Ptolemies in Egypt, as you say. And then there's the largest of the lot. The Seleucid Empire. The Seleucid Empire, which at this point is ruled by Antiochus III, who is the heir of Salukas, who had been one of Alexander's generals. And under Antiochus, who comes to be known as Antiochus, the Great, the Seleucid Empire reaches its furthest extent. So it ends up stretching from the Aegean all the way to the frontiers of India. And Antiochus understandably feels that as the ruler of an empire as massive of this, he doesn't need to put up with any nonsense from the
王国。当然还有其他的马其顿王国，托勒密埃及就是一个。是的，基本上有三个。一个是统治希腊的马其顿，但现在已经被罗马人击败了。正如你所说，还有埃及的托勒密王朝。然后是其中最大的一个，塞琉古帝国。塞琉古帝国此时由安条克三世统治，他是塞琉古的继承人，塞琉古曾是亚历山大的将军之一。在被称为“大帝”的安条克统治下，塞琉古帝国达到了其最广阔的疆域。它最终从爱琴海一直延伸到印度的边境。安条克理所当然地认为，作为一个如此庞大帝国的统治者，他不需要忍受来自
Romans, who he views as kind of upstart barbarians. And so when he crosses the Hellespont into Thrace, he moves from Asia into Europe and begins menacing the Greek cities on the eastern seaboard of the Aegean, so what's now the coast of Turkey, and the Roman send protests, he responds to the Roman ambassadors with absolute contempt. Yeah. And it's not just that he rules this massive empire. It's not just that he rules the Romans as barbarians who should keep out of Greek affairs. It's also the fact that by this point, he is in communication with the best possible man to advise him on how to defeat the Romans, and that is, of course, Hannibal. Right. So he's basically, his intention is to hire Hannibal, in the same way that you would
罗马人的任何废话，他视罗马人为暴发户式的野蛮人。所以当他越过赫勒斯滂海峡进入色雷斯，从亚洲进入欧洲，并开始威胁爱琴海东岸的希腊城市，也就是现在的土耳其海岸时，罗马人发出了抗议，他以绝对的蔑视回应了罗马大使。是的。不仅因为他统治着这个庞大的帝国，不仅因为他视罗马人为应该远离希腊事务的野蛮人。还因为此时，他正在与能为他提供如何击败罗马人建议的最佳人选进行沟通，那个人当然就是汉尼拔。没错。所以他的意图基本上是雇佣汉尼拔，就像你会
hire a football coach or a brilliant sporting star to be the star player for his team, presumably? To a degree. I mean, Hannibal at this point is still in Carthage. And it is not a hundred percent clear, initially, that Hannibal is in communication with Antiochus. He almost certainly is. But certainly the Romans feel that they cannot risk Hannibal kind of teeming up with Antiochus. And so they send a party of three senators to Carthage to say, look, you know, hand him over. And Hannibal is informed that this is going to be. happening and he plays it very, very cool. He kind of walks around the marketplace. He doesn't let anyone know that he's planning anything. And then the moment night falls, he slips out to a side gate where he's had a horse prepared for him. He climbs onto it. He gallops away to the coast where there is a fortress on a private estate of his. And there's a jetty with a galley and he gets onto the galley. There are men at all ready to take him away. And he makes his escape from Carthage. and this galley sails all the way
雇佣一名足球教练或一位出色的体育明星作为他球队的明星球员，大概是这样吧？在某种程度上。我的意思是，汉尼拔此时还在迦太基。起初并不百分之百确定汉尼拔在与安条克沟通。他几乎肯定是在沟通。但罗马人肯定觉得他们不能冒汉尼拔与安条克联手的风险。所以他们派了三名元老去迦太基说，听着，你知道，把他交出来。汉尼拔被告知这件事即将发生，他表现得非常非常冷静。他在市场上走来走去。他不让任何人知道他在计划什么。然后夜幕降临的那一刻，他溜到了一个侧门，那里已经为他准备好了一匹马。他骑上马，飞奔到海岸，那里有一个他私人庄园里的堡垒。那里有一个码头停着一艘桨帆船，他登上了船。船员们已经准备好带他离开。他从迦太基逃脱了。这艘船一直航行到
across the Mediterranean eastwards really kind of a journey back in history to the city of Tyre, the city from which the colonists who had originally founded Carthage came and he lands in Tyre and he then goes overland up through Syria and he
横跨地中海向东，真的就像是一次回到历史的旅程，回到了推罗城，也就是最初建立迦太基的殖民者所来自的城市。他在推罗登陆，然后陆路穿过叙利亚，他
ends up in the city of Ephesus on the Aegean coast of what is now Turkey and there he meets with Antiochus. So he's met the ruler of the Salukin Empire Antiochus and what does he say to him what happens he says listen I will be your coach and you know as you said I'm in I'm in five-year contracts there it is yeah unsurprisingly the
最终到达了现在土耳其爱琴海沿岸的以弗所城，在那里他见到了安条克。所以他见到了塞琉古帝国的统治者安条克，他对他说了什么？发生了什么？他说，听着，我会成为你的教练，你知道，正如你所说，我签了五年合同，就是这样。是的，不出所料，
romans are furious about this and so they send a delegation to Antiochus's court and it is said that attached to this delegation not an official member of it but going with with the delegation was Skippio Afrikanus. And he had come to persuade the Slukechid king not to go to war. Hannibal, of course, is busy urging him the opposite.
罗马人对此感到愤怒，所以他们派了一个代表团去安条克的宫廷。据说随这个代表团一起去的，虽然不是正式成员，但确实同行的是西庇阿·阿非利加努斯。他来是为了说服塞琉古国王不要开战。当然，汉尼拔正忙着劝他反其道而行之。
You know, the two old enemies, you know, they are like, I guess, kind of people who'd played football in the World Cup or something and now are on posing sides in the Champions League or something like that,
你知道，这两个老对手，你知道，他们就像，我想，就像在世界杯上踢过球的人，或者类似的人，现在在冠军联赛中处于对立面，或者类似的情况，
you know, as managers. Right. But it doesn't stop them. So the story goes, from meeting up again. They're having a chat and Scipio asks Hannibal which general do you think
你知道，作为教练。没错。但这并没有阻止他们。故事是这样说的，他们再次见面了。他们正在聊天，西庇阿问汉尼拔，你认为谁是
is the greatest of all time? This is a great conversation. This is exactly the conversation you'd want them to have. Hannibal answers and giving his reasons as he does so that obviously in first place
史上最伟大的将军？这是一次很棒的谈话。这正是你希望他们进行的谈话。汉尼拔回答并给出了他的理由，他说显然排在第一位的是
is Alexander the Great. And then he says, actually I would also place Pyrrhus in second and Pyrrhus was the guy who had invaded Italy a kind of few generations before Hannibal's invasion.
亚历山大大帝。然后他说，实际上我也会把皮洛士排在第二位，皮洛士就是那个在汉尼拔入侵前几代人入侵意大利的人。
And again, Hannibal gives reasons why Pyrrhus has the number two position. And Scipio, who's obviously a little bit disappointed that Hannibal hasn't mentioned him, then says, oh, and who would you put in the third place? And Hannibal then says, well, I'd put myself at number three. Brilliant. And Skipio, to give him credit, laughs at this and says, well, what if you had beaten me at the Battle of Zama? And Hannibal replied, oh, well, in that case, I would have put myself above Alexander
汉尼拔再次给出了为什么皮洛士排在第二位的理由。西庇阿显然对汉尼拔没有提到他感到有点失望，于是说，哦，那你把谁排在第三位？汉尼拔回答说，嗯，我会把自己排在第三位。太棒了。西庇阿，不得不说，笑着说，那么如果你在扎马战役中打败了我呢？汉尼拔回答说，哦，好吧，那样的话，我会把自己排在亚历山大
and above Pyrrhus and above all other commanders. God, Hannibal's not giving Skipio anything, is he? I think it's a wonderful conversation, and I like the fact that Skipio laughs. I mean, there hasn't been much laughter in this story. It's the only record we have of either Skipio or Hannibal laughing. And it's obvious from Hannibal's reply that he's a very witty and amusing man. Is he witty or is he just boastful? He is witty.
和皮洛士以及所有其他指挥官之上。天哪，汉尼拔一点面子都没给西庇阿，是吧？我认为这是一次精彩的谈话，我喜欢西庇阿大笑这一点。我的意思是，这个故事里没多少笑声。这是我们拥有的关于西庇阿或汉尼拔大笑的唯一记录。从汉尼拔的回答中可以明显看出，他是一个非常风趣幽默的人。他是风趣还是仅仅在吹牛？他是风趣。
The account that we have of it specifies that he was being witty. Oh, great banter. That in a sense, Skipio didn't quite know how to. to reply to it because he felt that Hannibal had had the better of him in that exchange. Are they speaking in Greek? They would presumably have been speaking in Greek, yes. Okay. When they met before Zama, they had interpreters because they didn't want to leave open any chance of their communications being mistaken.
我们拥有的关于此事的记载明确指出他当时是在开玩笑。哦，很棒的调侃。在某种意义上，西庇阿不太知道该如何回应，因为他觉得汉尼拔在那次交流中胜过了他。他们是用希腊语交谈吗？他们大概是用希腊语交谈的，是的。好的。当他们在扎马战役前见面时，他们有翻译，因为他们不想留下任何沟通被误解的可能性。
But I guess at this point they were speaking in Greek. So late in 192, Antiochus and the Seleucids invade Greece and the Romans respond with overwhelming force, don't they? So they route him at, of all places, Thermopyla. And when Antiochus withdraws across the Aegean, they pursue him into Asia, what is now, I guess, Turkey. And this army is led by Scipio's brother Lucius. So Scipio himself is there as an advisor. He's a sort of director of football.
但我猜此时他们是在用希腊语交谈。公元前192年末，安条克和塞琉古人入侵希腊，罗马人以压倒性的武力回应，不是吗？他们在温泉关击溃了他。当安条克撤退过爱琴海时，他们追击他进入亚洲，也就是现在的土耳其。这支军队由西庇阿的兄弟卢修斯率领。所以西庇阿本人作为顾问在那里。他就像是一个足球总监。
Yes. Yeah. Well, so it has said. But if, I mean, if he is actually, there, and it's much debated by ancient historians, he's not at the big shootout, which takes place at a place called Magnesia, where the Silucids are comprehensively defeated. Lucia Scipio is the victor. And if Skipio Afrikanus hasn't been present, neither was Hannibal.
是的。嗯，确实有人这么说。但如果，我的意思是，如果他真的在那里，而且古代历史学家对此争论不休，他并没有参加那场在马格尼西亚发生的决战，塞琉古人在那里被彻底击败了。卢修斯·西庇阿是胜利者。如果西庇阿·阿非利加努斯没有在场，汉尼拔也不在。
So by this stage, both the kind of the old war horses are fading into the background. But even so, the Romans remain paranoid about the mischief that Hannibal might get up to. And so part of the terms that Lucius imposes on his defeated foe is that Hannibal has to be surrendered into Roman hands. Antiochus has to quit Europe for good. He has to withdraw inland from the Aegean Sea board. Inevitably has to pay a massive indemnity. But the point is made, we are not going to allow you to have Hannibal. And there's a sense perhaps that that is for the Romans, although it might seem a minor demand is in fact the key one.
所以到了这个阶段，这两位老战马都在逐渐淡出背景。但即便如此，罗马人仍然对汉尼拔可能搞出的恶作剧感到偏执。因此，卢修斯强加给战败对手的部分条款是，汉尼拔必须被移交给罗马人。安条克必须永远离开欧洲。他必须从爱琴海沿岸向内陆撤退。不可避免地必须支付巨额赔款。但重点是，我们绝不允许你留下汉尼拔。也许有一种感觉，对于罗马人来说，虽然这看起来是一个小要求，但实际上是关键所在。
they hate him and fear him that much. Obviously, Hannibal knows that this is going to be happening. And so he's already made sure to Scarper. And for the next seven years, he leads the life of a fugitive. He's constantly finding refuge in, you know, a court here, a court there, and then being forced to go on the run again. The Romans are endlessly pursuing him. And finally, in 183 on a country estate in Bithynia, which is now northwestern Turkey,
他们如此憎恨和恐惧他。显然，汉尼拔知道这会发生。所以他已经确保逃跑了。在接下来的七年里，他过着逃亡者的生活。他不断地在这个宫廷或那个宫廷寻求庇护，然后又被迫再次逃亡。罗马人不断地追捕他。最终，在公元前183年，在比提尼亚的一个乡村庄园里，也就是现在的土耳其西北部，
he is cornered. And Hannibal, who had known what was coming, he'd had various kind of tunnels dug out from his house. But the Romans have cornered him. They block off the exits from the tunnels. And so they're, you know, Hannibal knows that he's got no way out. And so he does what Sof and Ispa had done many years before. And he glugs down some poison.
他被困住了。汉尼拔早就知道会发生什么，他让人从房子里挖了各种地道。但罗马人已经包围了他。他们封锁了地道的出口。所以，汉尼拔知道他已经无路可逃了。于是他做了索福尼斯巴多年前做过的事。他喝下了一些毒药。
And that is the end of him. And Rome's greatest enemy at the age of 64, at last, is dead. What a depressing. And downbeat and sadly kind of banal way for Hannibal's life to have ended. This extraordinary character who blazed like a meteor across the pages of the classical world. And now he just is, you know, he's in Turkey and his flipping basement of his bunker taking poison. Disappointing. Yeah, it's miserable.
这就是他的结局。罗马最伟大的敌人在64岁时终于死了。多么令人沮丧、消沉且悲哀地平庸的汉尼拔人生结局。这个非凡的人物曾像流星一样划过古典世界的篇章。现在他只是，你知道，在土耳其他地堡的地下室里喝着毒药。令人失望。是的，太悲惨了。
And in the long run, the poet Juvenile will write a poem. You know, he was this great guy who led elephants over the Alps. And now he's, you know, a dead loser in a basement. in Bethinia. We're all dead losers and ultimately Tom, that's the lesson of history. I mean, it's interesting. You say that because Scipio actually dies in the same year, 183. And he, unlike Hannibal had died in his bed of natural causes. He died very wealthy, adorned with honours, admired by his fellow citizens, secure in his fame as the man who had beaten Hannibal. But amazingly, he also had died as an exile. And the reason for this,
从长远来看，诗人尤维纳利斯会写一首诗。你知道，他曾是那个带领大象翻越阿尔卑斯山的伟人。而现在他只是一个死在比提尼亚地下室里的失败者。我们最终都是失败者，汤姆，这就是历史的教训。我的意思是，这很有趣。你这么说是因为西庇阿实际上死于同一年，即公元前183年。与汉尼拔不同，他死在自己的床上，死于自然原因。他死时非常富有，荣誉加身，受到同胞的钦佩，作为击败汉尼拔的人，他的名声稳固。但令人惊讶的是，他也死于流亡。而原因就是这个，
is that in 187, when Scipio returns with his brother Lucius from the Eastern campaign, and they are loaded down with wealth and money and cash and tremendous piles of plunder, this causes consternation in the Senate that these two Scipio brothers are now so wealthy that perhaps they might end up putting Rome itself in their shade. and Cato and his allies feel strong enough to go on the attack. And so they openly accuse Lucius of embezzlement. Remember, you know, Cato's background as a paymaster. He knows where to sniff around.
事情发生在公元前187年，当大西庇阿与他的兄弟卢修斯从东方战役归来时，他们带着堆积如山的财富、金钱和战利品。这在元老院引起了恐慌，因为这两位西庇阿兄弟现在如此富有，以至于他们可能会让罗马本身都黯然失色。加图和他的盟友们觉得有足够的力量发起攻击，于是他们公开指控卢修斯贪污。别忘了，加图曾担任财务官，他很清楚该去哪里搜寻证据。
And Scipio is accused of complicity in this. And he's so offended that he arrives in the Senate and he pulls out his account books and he rips them up before the full gaze of the Senate. it and indignantly, and to a degree justifiably, reminds his accusers of all the treasure that he has won for Rome. But the thing is, he's not prepared to stand and fight because he feels the humiliation of it too deeply. He's not going to bother swatting aside these pygmies as he sees them. Instead, he retires in high duchin to his country estate in Campania, so down by the Bay of Naples. and essentially for the rest of his life he's a broken man.
西庇阿也被指控共谋。他感到非常愤怒，于是来到元老院，当着所有人的面撕毁了他的账本。他愤慨地——在某种程度上也理直气壮地——提醒指控者他为罗马赢得了多少财富。但问题是，他并不准备站出来反击，因为他感到的羞辱太深了。他不想费心去拍死这些在他眼中如同侏儒般的人。相反，他愤然隐退到位于坎帕尼亚那不勒斯湾附近的乡村庄园，余生基本上成了一个心碎的人。
It's a triumph for the conservatives who had always hated him. And it's a triumph for what they see as an absolute point of principle that, and to quote Livy, no one citizen should be permitted an eminence so formidable that it prevents him from being questioned by the laws, i.e. even Scipio Africanus is not above the law. And of course there is one man in particular who had harried Scipio, to his death, and that was M. Porteus Cato. And Cato with Scipio, dead, has now inherited Scipio status as the most admired and prestigious man in the Senate. And the question is, what is he going to do with this prestige? So Cato, even by Roman standards, has a pathological
这对一直憎恨他的保守派来说是一场胜利。这也被他们视为一个绝对的原则问题，正如李维所言，不应允许任何公民拥有如此强大的地位，以至于使他免受法律的审判，也就是说，即使是大西庇阿也不能凌驾于法律之上。当然，有一个人特别热衷于将西庇阿逼上绝路，那就是老加图。随着西庇阿的去世，加图继承了西庇阿作为元老院中最受钦佩和最有声望的人的地位。问题是，他将如何利用这种声望？所以加图，即使以罗马的标准来看，也有一种病态的
hatred and contempt for Carthage, doesn't he? He does. and this is going to be very, very ominous for the Carthaginians. They're beaten, but they're still a name to conjure with, one of the wealthiest cities in the Mediterranean. But for Carthage, the clock is ticking, Tom. Very sad. So we will find out the fate of Carthage in the fourth and final episode of this epic series. So that final episode, the climax of this tremendous journey,
对迦太基的仇恨和蔑视，不是吗？确实如此。这对迦太基人来说将是非常非常不祥的预兆。他们虽然被打败了，但仍然是一个不可小觑的名字，是地中海最富有的城市之一。但对迦太基来说，时间不多了，汤姆。真令人难过。所以我们将在这一史诗系列的第四集，也就是最后一集中揭晓迦太基的命运。那么最后一集，这段宏大旅程的高潮，
will be out on Thursday. Is it possible there are any people out there who have not already been motivated to join the Restis History Club? Human beings are strange creatures so maybe there are. If you want to join it, now is your last chance before that episode.
将于周四发布。有没有可能还有人还没有被激励加入“历史余味”俱乐部？人类是奇怪的生物，所以也许有。如果你想加入，现在是那一集发布前的最后机会。
Go to Therestishistory.com and you can hear what happens to Carthage right away. What excitement. Tom, thank you very much and goodbye. Bye-bye. Tom, we have some absolutely unbelievable news to share with our listeners.
前往 Therestishistory.com，你就能立刻听到迦太基的结局。多么令人兴奋。汤姆，非常感谢你，再见。再见。汤姆，我们有一些绝对令人难以置信的消息要与我们的听众分享。
Probably the most exciting news who ever shared, no? Oh, I mean, no dispute. This is the most exciting news of all time. Right. So we are announcing the launch of some brand new rest is history merchandise. And the important thing about this is that it is exclusively for you, the members. Nobody else will be able to get this. That's absolutely right. So these are t-shirts that have been designed by one of our beloved Athelstands, Graham Johnson. And what he's done is to do designs for six of the biggest series that we have coming up over the next few months. Yes, so it's exclusive merch for our members. And the very first iteration is this amazing t-shirt. It really is a wonderful design. It's showing Hannibal as Hercules, crossing the Alps on an elephant. It's beautifully imagined, I have to say, and I would wear it with enormous pride myself. And it's so good that it has a Roman hydra with lots of different heads. Hannibal's chopped off some of them, but there are others with Roman helmets on. I mean, it could not be more epic. Epic is the word. Now, if you're a Roman hydra with lots of different heads, Hannibal's chopped off some of them. Hanobles chopped off some of them, but there are others with Roman helmets on. I mean, it's the word. Epic is the word. I mean, it is the word. I mean, it If you want to show your epic status as a member of the Restis History Club, I think it's important
可能是我们分享过的最令人兴奋的消息，不是吗？哦，我的意思是，毫无争议。这是有史以来最令人兴奋的消息。没错。所以我们宣布推出一些全新的“历史余味”周边商品。最重要的是，这是专门为你，也就是会员准备的。其他人将无法获得。完全正确。这些T恤是由我们敬爱的Athelstands成员之一，格雷厄姆·约翰逊设计的。他为我们未来几个月即将推出的六个大型系列设计了图案。是的，这是会员专属周边。第一款就是这件令人惊叹的T恤。这确实是一个很棒的设计。它展示了汉尼拔化身为赫拉克勒斯，骑着大象翻越阿尔卑斯山。我必须说，这构思非常精美，我自己也会非常自豪地穿上它。它好到甚至画了一只长着许多头的罗马九头蛇。汉尼拔砍掉了一些头，但还有其他长着罗马头盔的头。我的意思是，这再史诗不过了。史诗就是这个词。现在，如果你是一只长着许多头的罗马九头蛇，汉尼拔砍掉了一些头。汉尼拔砍掉了一些头，但还有其他长着罗马头盔的头。我的意思是，这就是那个词。史诗就是这个词。我的意思是，它就是那个词。我的意思是，如果你想展示你作为“历史余味”俱乐部成员的史诗地位，我认为这很重要
for you to wear one of these t-shirts. So when you're going out around town, when you see people, if you want to impress your husband or wife, wear this t-shirt or wear multiple t-shirts, get several, if you can, and you'll want to know how to get hold of it. The way you get to get hold of it is this. You go to the new, exciting Rest is History website, log in, and go to the member's merch section. And Tom, what about if you're an Apple member? Because I want to get this absolutely right.
让你穿上这些T恤。所以当你走在城里，当你见到人时，如果你想给你的丈夫或妻子留下深刻印象，穿上这件T恤，或者穿多件T恤，如果可以的话多买几件，你会想知道如何得到它。得到它的方法是这样的。你前往新的、令人兴奋的“历史余味”网站，登录，然后进入会员周边部分。汤姆，如果你是苹果会员怎么办？因为我想确保这一点完全正确。
I'm going to read out what I have been given. If you're an Apple member, you will need to join our members' mailing list to get access. Just send an email to the rest of the history at goalhanger.com with Apple member in the subject line and a screenshot of your membership. And we will add you in. And honestly, that couldn't be easier, could it, Dominic? No. So that's the rest is history at gollhanger.com with Apple member in the subject line.
我要读出我收到的内容。如果你是苹果会员，你需要加入我们的会员邮件列表才能获得访问权限。只需发送电子邮件至 therestishistory@goalhanger.com，主题行写上“Apple member”，并附上你的会员资格截图。我们就会把你加进去。老实说，这再简单不过了，不是吗，多米尼克？是的。所以就是 therestishistory@goalhanger.com，主题行写上“Apple member”。
Now, what if you're not a member of the show? or not yet a member of the show, I should say. Well, this is a wonderful opportunity for you to put that right and to get involved with the show. So not only will you be able to get your hands on this unique and uniquely cool example of merch, but you'll also get all the great benefits, early access to series, bonus episodes,
那么，如果你还不是节目的会员呢？或者我应该说，还不是节目的会员。好吧，这是一个绝佳的机会让你纠正这一点并参与到节目中来。所以你不仅能得到这件独特且酷炫的周边商品，你还将获得所有伟大的福利，包括系列节目的抢先观看权、额外剧集，
exclusive new miniseries, and so much more. I mean, those are just sensational benefits. Not only do you get to wear a Hannibal themed t-shirt, but there is so much else. So don't hang around, sign up, head to the rest is history.com. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
独家新迷你剧，以及更多内容。我的意思是，这些福利简直太棒了。你不仅可以穿上汉尼拔主题的T恤，还有这么多其他东西。所以别犹豫了，注册吧，前往 therestishistory.com。再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。